[Music]
pretty much the golden babes
you might want to tell lindsey mckenzie
he wants to mute
okay lindsay we have you muted
yep all please
okay like welcome everybody
so hopefully yep pretty much on the
money
right
okay the meeting's about to start those
on zoom
you
can you hear us there was nothing oh
there was all your discussion around the
protocol hello
members meetings in both chairs
indicators that they're probably hearing
more to
a structured debate rather than
right uh zoom members can you hear us
yes i can thank you right
okay
we'll restart this we've got live
streaming now so
welcome everybody to the tuesday at 7th
december 2021
infrastructure services meeting
we have zoom attendees uh lindsay
mckenzie we have calendar sopa
and councillor abbott
we have apologies from mr jeff grant
we don't have a public forum today
in this committee
and
we would like to accept a minor late
item for public excluded and that is a
verbal update on city centre streets
update on s street
reasons being noted can i have someone
please move
thank you
council lewis ii
ms ku
thank you uh put that all those in favor
against
right that takes us to
the first item which is the minutes of
the
infrastructure services meeting
tuesday second of november can i have
someone move that will we receive that
please thank you councillor arnold
seconded councillor skilt put the motion
all those in favor
against that is carried
right now we move on to
the three waters
section here um
recommendations um for the three waters
items that
we receive
the report from the lobby group
that the committee determine if it does
not wish to join the group
and if the
committee does decide to join the group
it authorizes fifteen thousand dollars
towards this group and also
no doubt signs the
mou
right so i'm gonna before we open that
for the debate on the subject um we'll
be
running a standing orders so that uh
each member of the committee gets to
speak once
um on the substantive motions but you
may ask
genuine questions at any time for
clarity
also
understanding orders counselor clark and
bringing notice of motion to
this committee is to open the debate and
he also gets to
have the
last say
so um without further ado councillor
clark i'm i'll let you
thank you chair um
and you've already
mentioned the recommendations that are
in the notice of motion just want to
read through the background for some of
those people that might be live
streaming that don't have access to the
agenda and some of the attachments i'll
just briefly go through that just a
couple of minutes
um so the background is there's a great
deal of pushback from councils across
the country
on the government's three water model
with only seven of 67 councils fully
supportive of the model it seems that
all councils support the direction of
government to improve drinking standards
and also to improve the environmental
outcomes of wastewater discharge from
water to land
what many of the councils do not agree
with are and there's a list of those
the way to achieve the government
direction and outcomes is not by the
current model of four entities the
councils will cross-subsidize each other
within each entity so one will pay for
the other
and so there are some winners and losers
in that game
the lack of priority between growth and
maintenance needs is not clear so those
that have high growth may get that at
the expense of councils are doing well
like our council that may need
maintenance work
that the ownership of the three water
assets has shifted to a joint council
ownership
that the entity of the government of the
governance group for the south island
entity has 21 councils but only six
votes
this undermines individual councils
control as opposed to ownership
that the co-governance model with
manafenua which gives equal governance
and control to councils and
monofilaments so they have six votes
each further undermines local control
that the original mou signed between the
dia on behalf of the government and the
councils allowed it for an opt-out
provision
and also clarified that we had an
ability to engage with our communities
about this reform
that minister mahuta and the government
have defaulted on both of these mou
commitments by mandating the reform
model
sitting alongside these concerns is the
lack of advocacy by our parent group
local government new zealand on behalf
of each council
lgnz has recently acknowledged and
apologized in our zone 5 6 lgnz meeting
for their undertaking of two actions
that have alienated many councils
firstly
the lgnz and the national zone
representers have changed the focus away
in dealing with and dealing with dia
from advocacy to
partnership and secondly they
subsequently signed a heads of agreement
with the dia which is a 20-page document
without consulting with member councils
and that document had a section 4 that
restricted and prevented
any negative comment by lgnz
around the three waters reform
and finally lgnz have accepted funding
from the dia without consultation with
member councils
with allegations in the media this
funding is to support the promotion of
the reform i've raised this concern
twice with stuart crosby who's the lgnz
president
and he has committed to making contact
with each council to clarify the nature
of that funding
it because many see that as an
inappropriate uh gesture to accept that
given section four of the heads of
agreement which restricts criticism no
contact has been made to member councils
in the last month
those who have been keeping in contact
with the developments of other councils
will observe the results of their public
engagement
my observation of the community
engagement by waimakariri and by manual
too are that both councils gave a
balanced picture to their community the
community feedback for both resulted in
support for improved water standards and
wastewater discharge but overwhelming
opposition to the water entity solution
that opposition was around about 95 in
both cases
in light of those concerns by council
and the frustration of the lack of
advocacy by local government new zealand
a group has been formed to lobby for
changes in the reform delivery space
and you'll see the attached memorandum
of understanding from helen lawboyz the
mayor of manuel 2 district council
this group is not formed to replace
local government new zealand but to
advocate for a review of the water
entity approach
which includes lobbying and media
campaigns i believe this group will have
a strong voice with government
and will also position local government
new zealand to return to his advocacy
role for the next two local government
reforms which is the future of local
government and the resource management
act reform
i note that local government new zealand
in the last week has recently put out
their forward strategy
and that is now sprinkled with advocacy
wording which is which is positive
i believe we should be involved with
this group and therefore i put forward
the two recommendations
and at the same time when we do get to
vote on it i would appreciate that the
vote be called on the division
thank you yes we can do that okay thank
you council clerk for that introduction
okay i'm going to now open the meeting
for comments or questions
counselor ludlow
question can you tell me how the amount
of fifteen thousand dollars has been
determined by the group and from which
budget we
intend to find this money because it's
not
a small sum
sorry do you want me to answer well um
okay i guess the use of the money um
council clerk if you wish to
take that first part
well i i guess that they're working on
assumption that they'll get around about
30 councils involved 20 already signed
up and there's probably another 20 like
us that are considering it so they're
looking at an overall program where they
will have tv advertising and media
advertising to
explain our position on our differences
with the dia going forward and push for
a better outcomes
on the issue where do we find that
internally well that's i guess that's
not my call i have a view on that but
if you ask me to view that i'll i'll
give you some
okay i'll i'll just pause there and
let them see
mr chair the suggestion is that if you
determine to join it then you refer it
to the next quarterly report
as unbudgeted operational expenditure
that should be allocated a code
from an under spent
line okay that's uh
he's satisfied with that answer
um yes i am at the moment
okay right let's go
can i
raise a concern about the wording used
to characterize the involvement of
manifenwa
on the water bodies
we are local
we have been local for more than 1200
years
we are also rate payers we are also
business investors i do not see
that manufenua sitting on a group should
be seen as not being part of
a open and democratic process because by
definition we are constantly under
scrutiny
i think that the
characterization of us as being other
is actually really harmful to the debate
that we are having and i would urge
that the groups using this be encouraged
to think
again about what how they use their
terminology and what they use it for
because this is a very divisive way of
characterizing what the process may be
there will be councillors there will be
lawyers there will be doctors there will
be politicians there will be all sorts
of people who are represented by the
people who sit on those boards and just
because they're brown doesn't mean to
say that they don't have acumen that
they don't have a vested interest in the
communities that they come from and live
in
we should see this as progress
not a threat thank you so do you see
anything
in the mou that you wish to change
um i'll reserve my comment on the mou
thank you right okay so you're just
raising that as a as your statement i
want it to be noted okay no no that's
fine
councillor munson
yeah just following on from that i note
that the comments which miss cook is
referring to other
comments that are written in councillor
clark's notice of motion
but i can't actually see them
specifically
listed or identified in the mou so i am
interested to know
whether this group is going to be
lobbying against the specific element
of the government's plan or not because
i certainly will have no intention of
voting for something in favor of
something that would be challenging
the co-governance model
well i see in the mo new mou no evidence
of that
no at all
okay and as you said this is
councillor clark has just listed some of
the issues that have been brought up
and there's no doubt that that issue has
been brought up so to deny that it
hasn't been brought up would be wrong
not to put it there whether it's right
or not is another issue
so will it be forming part of this
groups that's planned um uh challenge to
the government is my question
well we we can't answer that because we
the mou um does not specifically state
that
and the fact that if you
the the main issue is working
with the government over things so
nothing is specific
council lewis cheer in the mlu the one
statement does actually say i may read
it out verbatim that the go the
co-governance model with manufa
which gives equal governance control to
the councils
and manufacturer further undermines
local control i think that could be a
a paragraph of convict of
concern to let's cook
okay
counselor cracker
um i mean if we look at the principles
of why we're actually considering to
support such a thing um taking that what
ms cook has rightly said in placing that
aside from this argument at this point
um
this council has really expressed
displeasure at the way that the entire
free waters roll out has come about
um
is there a possibility that
we can go back to this group that
obviously
lobbying for and state our position on
it and that we would absolutely not uh
as a council support
uh as ms cooker said the um
inclusion of those principles
um strip that out of it and then um gain
some clarity on whether or not that's a
possibility well i i mean
this is just for for
an update on what's happening i know
that dunedin when they've spoken about
this have spoken very strongly about the
governance
um
the actual governance model not being an
issue christchurch has also spoken that
the governance governance issue
the governance thing is not an issue so
the issue with
the main councils are
is about the taking the assets and the
way it's going to be controlled that way
so they have no problem with the
governance it's just
the model they have the problem with
so we don't don't get too focused on the
governance side because even though it
is important it is not the essence of
the what's happening with these entities
okay
further counselors
okay well before i give it
thank you mr chair um i wanted to speak
on this particular motion because
i'm not comfortable i agree with miss
cook's comment and
i'm sorry but i i don't agree with what
you've said
as council lewis has pointed out there
is
a concerning reference to the
government's issue in the miu agreement
but setting that particular issue aside
i'm not in favour of joining this group
i think we do have to bear in mind that
a working group has been appointed and
they do carry a mandate that working
group is a very representative working
group i note that
mayor dalziel was on that working group
mia goff goth
tim kudovan
locally
that working group has been given the
mandate to look at all the issues that
are being talked about here
through this um
quality so-called ginger group
um i really cannot see
the
benefit that we would get
paying 15 000 to belong to a
a group we're not quite sure of how many
councils are going to join it we're not
quite sure what it intends to do in the
way of tv and media advertising i do
have that concern about the position
that we'll take on the government's
issue and the involvement of now
[Music]
i would be very uncomfortable to see
to see air council
join this particular proposed group and
i will be voting against that being
done
thank you all right other
anyone else questions
yes councillor evan
oh thank you for that um i agree with um
what councilor safer said it seemed to
me to be a duplicate of the governments
and the governments that are proposed
um have the same mandate so i
don't see a point in spending fifteen
thousand dollars for
the same mandate
okay
thank you for that
right anyone else which is yes
yes
um i agree with uh councillor sober as
well
i think that um fifteen thousand dollars
isn't
much really when you look at the
costs that are going to be involved
whichever way you go
um
and i think you've just got to accept
that
the government was voted in
they made it clear they'd be engaging in
reforms especially those related to the
environment
and they won and
they i think have a democratic right to
therefore
impose their will and
they're going to
i think probably give a few token
gestures towards
the group
but
[Music]
the strength is in the big councils and
what they're going to do rather than
a lot of minority councils
council rana it's not a popular decision
i know but
i think it's the right one i support
the um
[Music]
the motion here
the recommendations and the reason being
is
i think it's our duty to do all we can
to preserve the assets
that our communities paid for
and you know worked for over the last
100 or so years
i mean we need to do all we can to to
our ownership we've got good assets um i
don't i don't want to see us
funding councils that that haven't done
that our ratepayers have done that for
us over the last
100 years and i think it's our duty to
to maintain that management of it so i
support
doing all we can to ensure that happens
and i don't necessarily have a great
deal of faith in the working group
as it's been set up by the government
okay
council ladler you're here with your
statement yes
i've had my question thank you chair
um i'm uncomfortable with the proposal
for for a couple of reasons but i also
understand the rationale behind it
because
we are concerned about the process and
what was originally promised
and and what is now being
mandated
and and i do have an issue with that
what i have a concern with is the
potential for us as a member
organization to
undermine lg nz
and
and i agree that they have not
handled the situation
as well as they could have done
but that's a longer term
uh involvement for us and and and i
guess
it it sets
potentially a habit that could be formed
with with some of the other issues that
are coming up
um if if i hacked back to um the
previous uh
chief executive of lg did malcolm
alexander when he went around councils
he said that
they remember organization
representing our sector to central
government
and it didn't help them to advance the
cause when there were 90 different
points of view going forward behind what
it was they were being asked
as an organization to do i think we've
got a little bit within within our own
house the lgnz has to do to to tidy up
um but i really am
nervous about
the potential damage that
being part of this process does and also
the language around the co-governance
model i'm i'm not comfortable with that
at all
okay
counselor kit yeah thank you uh cumin uh
i support the motion
um i'm old enough to go back to the
early days of a macabre city council
when we had a city engineer by the name
of ken ballinger
and him and his staff and
over the years i think king started with
us in the 1950s early 60s
and we have a well-maintained
infrastructure that includes stormwater
rainwater and drinking water
what i'm upset about that minister
mahuta has quoted
quite often saying there are over 30 000
new zealanders
become very ill drinking substandard
water in new zealand that is supplied by
new zealand local authorities
well i haven't heard anyone getting ill
drinking water from our water supply and
i'd like to ask our director erin logan
if she can
make a comment to this if there's been
any reported
reports on our locals or visitors
becoming violently ill drinking our
local water
tell me an answer
um
look i'm happy definitely during my time
here there's been no such reports um and
nothing that's been made that i've been
aware of in our recent history either
thank you very much that's the answer i
thought i would receive but i had to ask
it
and and i believe the fifteen thousand
dollars is a small amount to support
those other councils so i'm in favor of
them
thank you councillor kit uh council
crackit you've got your statement now
yeah um it's just gonna be a short one
because uh this is we've litigated this
in the first instance and quite a few
times but um
our feelings or our sentiment on how the
government has hand of three waters
um i
support uh like
councillor um arnold here actually that
anything that we can do to
uh preserve the legacy of our four
bearers is um and for the future of our
mokopuna is something that i
personally believe we should have
absolutely be doing however it's not
quite clear enough for me
um exactly what that 15 000 would be
contributing to in my i'm really
uncomfortable with the
the sector there that does reference the
co-governance structure and any
inferencing that um
monitor i shouldn't have a voice at the
table was just not something i can
support so
i think it's going to be a no for me
right any anyone else okay i'll
i'll jump in before
i pass it to councillor clark
now
what uh councillor arnold has raised is
something very important and if you look
at it yeah
sorry
councillor sopher have you got a
question
i had a question mister yep
yes i i do have a question um
partly inspired by what councillor
ludlow said um
the question that i did have in the back
of my mind was
if we did join with some group
has any reflection been given to the
the
undermining
this
this group could result in doing to lgnz
when we have such important reforms as
local government reform and remain
still very much on the agenda in a very
short time
well i don't think we have anyone here
to answer that but in my view there
would be no
it would have no impact on that
whatsoever this is a separate issue it's
an important issue and has nothing to do
with those other subjects you've raised
that's my review on it but
um i don't think there's anyone here who
can answer that
okay
hold up just a moment there
yeah
claire has
read reading the uh
by mere will boys
the the desire is not to have a negative
impact on the relationship with lgbt
from member councils
okay
right thank you
yeah council lewis i know i made a
mistake
thank you comment about my my voting i
just wonder if we vote for this are we
then
questioning effectively the ability of
the of the
advocate group
that's been set up or suggesting or they
have no authority to actually mandate
anything what comes that comes out of
their discussions
are we actually questioning their
ability no i think this has been stated
as a separate group that will be asking
different questions and putting forward
different alternatives
the would you be contributing to that
um well i imagine the mou gives us that
opportunity to contribute yeah so in
other words if we vote for this motion
we'd be doubling up on that
doubling up on doubling up on
the ability to ask us questions that
need full and glasses questions
wow revisiting it twice or revisiting it
no i don't think so this group will be
doing completely different things to
what uh that other group with lgnc is
doing next year council cracker another
question
no no you don't give answers to the
statements sorry
council announces
right
looking around the table again right
i'll
just
start the council arnold raised the
point that we should do all we can as
elected members and he's dead right
um the very first
item in our code of conduct of values
states that we
do what's best for the city
and i believe believe that the proposal
for the three waters entity is not in
the best interest for this city at all
and if you look at the financial
information that was put forward
by a financial team that showed
what it would cost per rate payer in the
year
2050 something
versus what the dia put forward they
were virtually identical
except
in our budgeting over that period of
time we had included 90 odd million
dollars on getting
wastewater
um
solution to land as instead of a
discharge to the estuary so there alone
is a 90 million dollar gap
they're doing business a year as usual
in their financial proposal to us
we've got all this extra work done which
we will not get the other thing is that
minister mahuta says there'll be nine
and a half thousand new jobs
now how
this baffles me how do you
do something so much more efficiently
and cheaper
and create nine and a half thousand new
jobs now
this is and these guys won't be working
for charity
uh these new nine hundred thousand
positions so the maths again what i'm
seeing is heading for
is
something like uh kiwi build on a
biblical scale
um
the lgnz
group is really not a group advocating
anything new it's rubber stamping it's
basically a clayton's
group that will see this through
so
my view on this it is not good for
invercargill and that's what i'm here
saying and i'm voting for what's best
for invercargill
so councillor clark i'm going to pass it
back to you
yeah thank you chair just a couple of
reflections on what's been said listen
carefully
um no suggestion from the from the
members of the
new group that none of it doesn't have a
voice what is concern is the size of
that voice
so that's the issue the issue is not
one-off partnership it's one of
co-governance which some of those
councils do not agree with
and so just give you an easy example of
that
all significant decisions made by the
water entity in the south island need to
have a 75
stakeholder approval given there's 12
votes
so six
represent 21 councils and 1.2 million
people
and the other six represent none whenua
with about 50 000
people representing them um
not a fan of i can veto just about
everything it's of significance and so
that's an
area of unease and so what they're
saying is if you're going to have 12
votes maybe the split should be 9 3 so
there's not that veto right so i'm just
reflecting what i'm hearing from other
mayors
everybody tiptoes around this issue
because there's
an unease about talking about it but you
need to put on the table to be able to
deal with it
the mou that's promoted for the new
group it's quite clear about where it
wants to go it has an opt-out clause at
any stage it does not bind us to
anything
we have a voice on every issue as
opposed to local government tends to
have representatives for zones and so we
our voice is not often heard and this
one we will have a voice
um and we can certainly have a voice on
manufenue and anything else that we want
as well but the key issue is the
solutions that have been thrown up by
the government on the issue of the 15
000 i think that's a very small amount
to a council that operates over 100
million dollars a year and if you cast
your mind back earlier in the year when
we got the first thompson report we
committed 750 000 to that reform process
we haven't spent anywhere near that
amount we've got money in the budget for
that
and so i didn't hear anybody complaining
around the table about this three
quarters of a million so this 15 000 is
quite small the other issue is the issue
i think a couple of my colleagues raised
about what about future reforms well we
have two reforms that are facing us
rma reform and by my way the most
important one even though not the
biggest is the future of local
government
and
with the current heads of agreement
that's in place between
local government new zealand and dia i'm
not clear
that doesn't run across more than just
the three waters framework and if it
does run across and i expect it does
we will have an advocacy group that's
not allowed to publicly criticize the
government on anything so um i don't
accept that
that that's a good mechanism going
forward this group however is not here
to undermine local government new
zealand it wants it to work better for
us so uh hence why i put the uh two
recommendations
thank you council clark
uh that's all that's all done in dustin
now i'm sorry mrs copeland we we had an
opportunity for the report no sorry
about that that's
the way standing orders work so
um i'm now going to put the motion um
all those in favor
yeah okay so i'm going to move the
motion that uh and second
actually i'm going to let councillor
clark
do you want to move them i'll move and
buy division please yeah
the
recommendations are looking for
direction yes
need to
you are moving the notice of motion yep
i am
and that is the three listed there sorry
that's the two
the two listed there sorry about that
okay and we have a second day for that
please yes
councillor keith is going to second that
okay so notice motion the icc agreed to
the detached mou and become a partner
council for the purpose of advocating
for a different solution to the
government's three water
and brackets water entity reform and
that
icc commit to the fifteen thousand
dollar partnership
mem membership fee so so again the
second door was
counsellor kit
right i'm gonna put that motion now that
okay i'm going to call provision so can
you please show hands when you vote all
those in favor
arnold scout kit and cottager
okay we have that and all those against
thank you
okay that has been defeated thank you
for people's time there for you for my
benefit chair can you just confirm how
many were in the
opposed
not sure i have nine against
um ms cook mrs coat and councillors
ludlow amundsen lush crackit shadbolt
thank you
right thanks for that
chair do we now
i think it's so appropriate that we move
that the committee receives the report
okay if you'd like to move that i am
i'll see you we're good
thank you
i'll put that we received the report all
those in paper all right all right
against
that's carried
right
okay i think we're
stopping a road now
let's move
should we find out about that
okay
welcome heather
stopping of the lagon street road bluff
um approach or an adjacent property
owner
um to
um commits the roadstopping process and
the view of purchasing
that possibly next to them
the parcel of land is
um at the end of lightning street um we
are
opposite the entrance to the bluff
symmetry
um quite a way throughout the hill um
the preliminary investigation
of the title and how council uh
received the land doesn't um negate that
from being
stopped and um so we're asking to start
the process
okay
council ludlow thanks chad good question
so i have no problem with being asked to
stop the road and to
go through a process of disposing it but
aren't we obliged to if that's the case
to um send it to market rather than just
negotiate with an adjacent property
owner
so we'd put it to market
thank you
thanks
i'm going to remove the two
recommendations
okay thank you look i've just got one
question that was um alluded to me by a
member of the public and that's as would
is there potential
that
part of this land was the old bluff tip
that that is not anticipated that it was
right quite significantly up the hill
and it never formed part of the process
for the
investigation of the
public consultation yes council life
is the size of the section does it
qualify that this individual dwelling
could be built on that does it stand as
a section in its own right
okay
i believe that section actually backs on
to the bower street uh at the band
street um sections that run
in parallel
behind this yes there is a piece of land
that has been previously stopped and
disposed off
um which one's further down the hill um
this one
i was trying to see the whole
touchscreen you know to see so where the
entrance
it
is
it's the sections that they run down
behind it and then there's that road
that's
behind beside that
um
sorry i just interrupt here council sopa
has left the meeting
council sorry we lost your video
sorry i
had to
change the space i'm in and the php
offices
okay sorry about that that's okay
yes council lash can i make a comment as
well absolutely
just haven't gone and looked at that
section yesterday it's one of the very
few sections in bluff that can see both
the harbour and the ocean so it's a
very very significant and desirable
section as well too so i think that
needs to be noted it's not just a um
yeah it's it's a bit of land that um has
an extraordinary aspect so um
particularly for a town that's short of
sections i think um it could be a
desirable place for someone to put a
home yourself
okay any other questions or comments for
either
[Music]
no
right we've got the uh two
recommendations
there
and they actually um
we received the report
but
it will go to market we need to mention
that
right but we don't need to include in
the resolution
it'll come back to council okay then in
case with
that case we have the two
recommendations there can someone please
move that i did oh you did
seconded on zoom my counselor abbott
i'd put that all those in favor
that is carried
it takes us now to activities reports
and uh
erin do you want to
start with that
thank you chair
um i'll split this into two sections the
leisure and recreation section and the
infrastructure section um just noting
though that steve giblin who would
normally provide any comments in
relation to
leisure and recreation is absent
and so we have caroline as our parks
manager here to
provide any answers
that elected members may wish to ask
um so
i'll start
chairs happy by opening the floor on the
leisure and recreation section yeah
yes councilman just a comment um thank
you very much for the explanation about
what's happening with the chinese garden
i recently went through a walk through
there expecting to see it um you know
all beautiful and grown up um after
opening and was a bit concerned with
what i saw but now that i've got an
explanation thank you very much
yeah the questions yes counselor
one
well it's not really a question it's
just a comment um i'm looking at the
internments in cremation and am i in
writing interpreting that uh
since the pandemic started their
death tolls dropped from 700 down to
250.
is it with that sort of showing there
like your insurance you know in the
cemetery you know i know showing
cremations as opposed to uh
as to burials but the whole thing looks
like the total death rates right like
right down from
sort of 700 per annum down to
250. i see you got a scooter too
that's a very uh
yeah look we can't
mr day might want to start something
yeah
thank you councillors um look not my
area but the challenge with the report
is that that is a year to date figure
so
what you're comparing the other four
years is the four years full 12 months
and that year to date is only up until i
believe it's the end of um
or yeah it's financial year so it's only
about five months worth so there's
another yeah seven months that's quite
good because it's better than the road
toll entire road in new zealand
there's more to live for here sanitizing
and wearing masks
right uh
council clark yeah thank you chair uh
just just as a comment for future uh
activity report i wonder whether we
could get a report that includes uh the
progress being made on anderson house
i think we had one last activity report
i'm happy to provide here we thank you
no no nothing further on lesion right
okay
okay so just a couple of points i'd like
to make on the infrastructure component
um one just being that since the report
was put forward
um we've had further confirmation back
from christchurch city council with
regard to their wastewater treatment
plant the potential to use some of the
aerators that we had at clifton um
they're looking to take two of these
smaller aerators that we had on site um
so we'll be drawing up an agreement uh
to make sure that if
the worst happens and we suddenly
require those that they would be able to
swiftly be returned to us but we also
wanted to make sure that from an
environmental perspective that we were
able to help christchurch city in
whatever way we reasonably could
the other piece is just a note that you
will have seen the new parking machines
going out around the city
and just a reminder that the go live
date for those is monday the 13th
and that there's been quite an intensive
piece of work done in terms of briefing
our internal team um and having those uh
that team ready with all of the
information required to be out on the
streets uh assisting customers uh next
week
and the other piece around just a quick
verbal update around anderson house
so the work is
underway the scaffolding has been
completely erected
they are in the process of removing or
lowering the first chimney
and work is underway on removing the
cladding from internal walls for the
strengthening work that needs to be done
internally
at this stage the project's on track
both from a program and a budget
perspective
and we've also had a a recent uh site
safety audit um with good results at
that site also
thank you
right any questions on that side council
cracker i've got a question um that's
more to point out something that's
already existed in the report um how i
i've seen a lot of redirect online about
our fantastic new parking solutions and
sort of saying like being a bit negative
about it going oh you know this is
another way to get more money out of us
but can you confirm for me
um just how much that how much free
parking that a user will get per day and
um what the hour cost is currently is it
cheaper is more expensive
uh so sorry in the absence of uh mr
pearson not being here today because
he's unwell um i'll i'll talk to it at a
reasonable level um obviously there's an
initial period of of 30 minutes of
parking at no charge which is different
to what we've had previously
um
then the for those shorter stays where
you're popping into the shop for a half
an hour or an hour an hour and a half um
the parking would on average be cheaper
than what you would see at the moment
that being said if you were looking to
park right outside of the shops and be
there all day and go to work perhaps
then you would find that it would be a
more expensive charge and you would be
most likely better off in one of our
various parking buildings that we have
around the city but very much the aim is
to support local business in terms of
keeping those parks turning over
definitely time for people to come in
visit different stores and leave again
but looking to discourage that uh
all-day parking out in in those prime
locations
thank you that answers my question
that's exciting
okay
everyone's good there
right thanks that brings us to the end
of the public session of the
infrastructure meeting now
um it's just a procedural thing that's
going to happen here so i'll ask
everyone in the public gallery to stay
you don't have to leave at this moment
so
we're going to can i have someone move
that we go into public excluded please
for sure ms cook
thank you
miss coote and that's with the knowledge
that we are receiving that monolate item
so i'll put that all those in favor
against carried i'll now adjourn the
public excluded meeting
and uh you'll have councillor
up here
ready
thank you
and i think there's still staff seat up
over here
all right councillor staff members of
the public welcome along i'll
declare this extraordinary meeting of
the performance policy and partnerships
committee open
acknowledging of course that we are also
on zoom
and
streaming uh welcome on zoom to uh mr
mckenzie and councillors abbott and sopa
we have an apology from jeff grant would
somebody like to move that that's
received councillor lewis councillor
scout put that all in favor
against kerry
um
first item will be to receive
a submission in public forum
um then i'll go through the
the ground rules for the receipt of the
paper and the discussion that's going to
to follow
so first of all if we've got um
sophie and neura is it
if you'd like to come up there's a table
at the middle there
welcome along
uh the floor is yours yes
um
hi everyone thank you for taking the
time
can you hear me okay
sorry no counselor edward's shaking his
head so if you could pull that and
can we just check that it's turned on
one moment
have enough there we go
thank you um so my name's sophie fevery
i've recently moved to southland i've
been a doctor for 16 years and a rural
gp for the last nine years and i have
two school-aged children
um and does everyone know this is in
regards to the decision about whether
the unvaccinated people can go into yes
places yeah only thing we're discussing
cool
just thought i'd make that clear
um
so i'm going to talk about a few things
briefly the severity of the pandemic the
evidence around the effectiveness of the
vaccines to reduce transmission
and some reasons why some people can't
be vaccinated
so firstly i'd like to acknowledge the
fear that has gripped the country since
last march
i myself was initially terrified of
cover 19 and i was in fact the one who
started the masks for all campaign last
year with michael baker
the good news is that as more data's
come out about covert 19 it's clear that
it isn't the ebola-like plague that we
thought it was last year
turns out that the death rate from
covert 19 is around 0.15
and if you're under 70 years of age it's
only 0.05
the even better news is that there's a
number of preventative and early
treatment options available
such as vitamin d zinc vitamin c inhaled
steroids and a number of others
so with a death rate similar to a
moderately severe flu
and early treatment options available
the question needs to be asked are all
these measures
and the segregation of society
justified
the next question that should be raised
is whether the current covert 19
vaccines actually prevent transmission
of covert
last year i held out much hope
that the vaccines would promise the end
of the pandemic
this year
i've lost faith in vaccines as the
solution to the pandemic as i've watched
the scientific literature
so an important study from the european
journal of epidemiology which i'll leave
with you compared data from 68 countries
and 2 947 counties in the united states
in this study the authors compared
vaccination rates for each country with
the covert 19 cases per million people
they concluded
there appears to be no discernible
relationship between percentage of
population fully vaccinated and new
covert 19 cases in the last seven days
in fact there's no evidence that this
vaccine reduces transmission
a study from the uk showed that
household transmission rates of covert
19
were roughly the same
regardless of vaccination status and
i'll leave that study with you as well
so why is this
why do vaccination rates not seem to
correlate with covert 19 rates
and why do studies show that the vaccine
doesn't seem to prevent transmission
we have a couple of reasons
so firstly this is not a sterilizing
vaccine a sterilizing vaccine is one
that absolutely stops you getting the
disease and passing it on measles is
pretty good like that
this is not a sterilizing vaccine and it
wasn't designed
to prevent infection it was designed to
reduce the severity of disease if you
did get it
the vaccinated can still become infected
and pass on the virus and i'd like to
quickly read something from a ministry
of health guideline that came out to us
came out to doctors ministry of health
position statement on the management of
unvaccinated individuals in health care
settings
on page three they just mentioned
when there is high covert 19 vaccine
coverage above 80 of eligible people
transmission is more likely to occur
from a vaccinated than an unvaccinated
individual and that's in the ministry of
health document which i can leave with
you
secondly
the vaccine effectiveness wanes with
time
an oxford university study showed that
vaccine effectiveness decreases by 22
per month after vaccination
by six to eight months the vaccine is
doing almost nothing
thirdly the vaccine was designed for the
wuhan variant of the virus which was two
years ago
it's expected that viruses will mutate
to escape the vaccines just like
bacteria mutate to escape antibiotics
delta appears to be a moderately vaccine
resistant variant
studies showed that the vaccines were
much more effective against the alpha
variant compared to the delta variant
and in fact recent studies show that
those who become infected with delta
have similar viral loads that's the
amount that you carry in your upper
airways regardless of their vaccination
status many studies have confirmed that
viral load thing recently
the final point i'd like to raise is
that in my professional experience
most people who are not vaccinated have
very legitimate reasons for not taking
the vaccine
some
are people who have had significant
reactions to the first shot
and understandably are reluctant to get
another
some are people with personal or family
histories of heart conditions blood
clotting cancer or autoimmunity
and they're waiting for long-term
studies to confirm that it's going to be
safe for them
amongst my own patients i have
personally seen autoimmune flare-ups
worsening of cancers
heart attacks and blood clots after
vaccination
the ministry of health will not give
exemptions for these reasons but as a
medical doctor i see these as legitimate
reasons to be cautious about taking the
vaccine
no studies have been carried out to
assess effects on fertility so i can
understand that
people of childbearing age may be
cautious
and many people with religious
convictions do not want to take vaccines
that have been tested on aborted fetal
cells
these are just some of the reasons that
people in our community remain
unvaccinated and there are many others
that are just as valid
so to recap covert 19 has a fatality
rate in the ballpark of a moderately
severe flu
there are early treatment options
available
the vaccines do not prevent transmission
and there are some very valid reasons
that people can't be vaccinated so i
therefore see no medical reason that the
unvaccinated should be excluded from
these important places in society
and just a final point it was really
interesting to hear the um discussion on
the three waters and thank you for
letting us listen into that
um and i think we might be able to all
agree that we're in a period in which
the power of local government seems to
be
reducing
but i would be proud to see the
invercargill city council resist that
thank you
thanks sophie uh we have time for a few
questions if there are any councillors
councillor lewis
i was told there was one speaker oh
sorry
apologies sorry um okay my name is nikki
harrison and i'm a registered nurse and
a south londoner i endorse measures to
limit the impact that covert 19 will
have on our community but i have
concerns for individuals value valued
contributing members of our community
who will be disadvantaged by any policy
change regarding passports only in
public facilities
the impacts of segregation and
discrimination are going to have
profound and long-lasting effects
excluding people from public facilities
that they pay for with their rates or
through rent is discriminatory when for
reasons outside of their control they
cannot safely take the vaccine
some people didn't have a choice of
being fully vaccinated
people require access to these important
public facilities libraries have been
recognised as essential to the community
hence why they are publicly funded and
accessible to all
children learn and are supported in
education and personal interests adults
are able to support the education and
skills people can join social groups
there's important public events
networking and essential community free
internet ensures digital equality and
access for all of society if we lose
this the consequences of lost access to
education at all levels will be found
for years to come
and wholly recovering lost education is
unfavorable unfeasible
the library is a significant part of our
education system for the whole
population and can be argued to be the
most accessible form for everyone
i speak not only for myself
naomi a supporter here with us
represents the estimated 130
homeschooling families in invercargill
who rely on regular access to the
library for educational needs at an
average of four children per family this
is 520 children who need access they do
not have the support of a school behind
them and without the resources applied
by the library their children's
education will suffer
homeschool children over age 12 who are
vaccinated are also included in all
mandates and will be excluded from
essential educational activities home
schoolers have already found the loss of
the library's regular groups and clubs
which they attended every week that were
stopped due to covered restrictions they
have lost access to the stadium play
groups and indoor venues that they hired
during winter weather if they do not
have the library in the pool they will
not have anywhere
what's more it is the right necessity of
every new zealand child and adult to
learn to swim in a country surrounded by
beaches and traversed by rivers it is
imperative that our citizens are safe in
and around water the average yearly
fatal drowning rate for new zealand is
81 lives lost per year not included as
the many near-misses that have lasting
effects
if the swimming pool is mandated many
children will be excluded from entry
simply because their parents are
unvaccinated
this will they will be disadvantaged and
put at risk because of the passport
policy
adults included
many adults particularly immigrants and
former refugees who i have personally
worked with are adult swim learners and
would be put at risk if excluded
consider also other beneficial effects
of exercise and socialization that would
be lost jiren another supporter here is
a working dad who is vaccinated but he's
very concerned and shocked the proposed
levels of segregation and how that will
impact our society he's personally not
affected but is set up for those that
are and what that means for the
well-being of individuals
he is not the only fully vaccinated
person i've spoken with who shares the
same sentiments many think this way
peter another supporter here wishes to
express that such discrimination is
unjust and penalizes people who have the
right to choose the health care
treatment as per the new zealand bill of
rights section 10 and 11.
six days ago the macarthur city council
posted a facebook post outlining the
restrictions under the new protection
framework
99 of comments of the post are in favor
of your decision to keep public
facilities such as the library and pull
open
other councils in new zealand are
keeping public facilities open to all
to change your policy now would be
against the clear wishes of the
community people can see that while we
need to care for one another and keep
each other safe it cannot be at the
expense of a significant group of
society and the division would occur
covert 19 and the government response to
it have impacted people in different
ways often amplifying existing
structural inequalities in income and
poverty socioeconomic inequalities and
education and skills and
intergenerational inequalities with
particular effects on families with
children young people and the elderly it
has impacted relationships social
development and mental health the
pandemic itself has exacerbated existing
inequalities and differences let us not
create new ones i understand the impact
that covert will have on the health of
individuals and the healthcare system
i wish for no one to suffer and endorse
effective public health measures to
limit covered spread but let us not
cause unnecessary suffering in other
areas it is important that you consider
responsibility for all aspects of health
and wellbeing not only one narrow sliver
we must think holistically
in this time it is important to not lose
sight of our humanity our empathy and
love for one another forcing segregation
onto individuals when it is not
justified and doesn't improve safety
outcomes only enforces the fracturing of
society and encourages divisive
attitudes we must ensure that in all
things we protect and uphold the dignity
of all people
covert health crisis will not be with us
forever but the attitudes that we
encourage now may never be eliminated
from the fabric of society
morals ethics and principles are most
important in a time of crisis that is
when we must hold fast to them and allow
them to steer our decisions they exist
for the crisis when our thinking is
colored by fear discrimination is
unethical
let our city be brave and keep a
long-term view of things we must foster
love and inclusion even in a time of
fear in order to emerge from this as
unmarried community as possible the cure
cannot be worse than the problem
in our community it is important that
there is always a place where all are
welcome we all can enter regardless of
disability status income and personal
choices nothing strips a person of their
worth
if you choose to mandate for passes only
a significant portion of our community
will be unfairly discriminated against
and leave with no space where they are
welcome
your facilities are the only community
spaces left
to change this is unacceptable in
democracy in a nation such as new
zealand that cares for all of its
citizens equally
vaccine passports only and a public
facility will do more social harm than
good
a safe community actively protects
against discrimination
please protect public health and
maintain safety from infection but do so
in a way that empowers respects and
includes all people
thank you
thank you um before i go to the two
people at indicated questions i think
it's important that i point out that
this is not about reversing decisions
today is actually the first day we are
making one okay
so governors haven't had a chance to
make a decision prior to today
councillors in your questions they need
to be questions
i'm not interested in
engaging in debate with our submitters
at this point so councillor lewis was
first then councillor clark thank you
thank you
councillor thank you leslie thank you
very much for you both of you your
comments um
i wish we had more time to ask lots and
lots and lots of questions because
so many of these issues have been raised
in public media and by various
professionals whom i've got contact
perhaps i've just asked one particular
question
what do you think of of the patrick
apache over a new pfizer drug that's
been controlled
um i actually
honestly don't know much about it i do
know that
ivamectin is probably one of the safest
drugs in the world has
over four billion doses been given no
one's died of it and there's over 62 uh
randomized controlled trials so showing
that overall it's useful
um so personally i feel really
comfortable using ivamekton um i know
that that's received a lot of bad media
press though but i sometimes think you
have to follow the money and realize why
has that been uh gone like that so
honestly don't know about the new drug i
hope it works but again
um i guess i like to see
longer term safety trials with things um
and so i'd probably still be somewhat
hesitant um yeah
yeah i've admitted into nutrition one
because we don't have tapeworm new
zealand anymore that's not a question
councillor a dewey councillor thank you
louis
councillor lewis thank you i'm cheering
the meeting that's you're getting into a
debate not i wanted to ask you the call
can we get to the question quickly no no
that'd be fine thank you thank you sorry
councillor clark
yeah for sophie just uh three questions
very quick ones um the
director general of health has said that
to us that
the new zealand community that non-vexed
uh people spread the virus
at a quicker rate
than those that have asked would you
like to comment on it i would absolutely
i'd dearly love to see the studies
that he gets that from um because i have
i've been an expert witness for the high
court um case for the board of workers
um i've looked at this very very
in-depth with simon thornley who's also
worked with international uh
doctors you know peter mcculloch and
byron bridal a top vaccinologist and we
see no evidence that they pass it on at
a higher rate at all i think there might
be a confusion there when they say this
10 times thing
at the moment if you look at the numbers
so every week i'm calculating the
auckland numbers
and
they
are showing the vaccinated are showing
symptomatic covert 19 disease at a
higher rate than unvaccinated than
vaccinated people
and that's what it's meant to do it's
meant to make you less symptomatic
but we don't actually know what the
levels of asymptomatic infection are and
in the pfizer trials there was no
testing for asymptomatic infection
the
asymptomatic
those with asymptomatic infections have
exactly the same viral load whether
they're vaccinated or unvaccinated
so
and with that household transmission
study that i've got here for you
households they're the places where you
pass the virus on the most and there was
no change in transmission so i just
don't know where dr bloomfield gets that
from but i'd be interested to see
sure just another question in relation
to dr glenfield
um
on the on the media recently uh he said
that the non-vex population will be
around about ten percent
at this stage um
and
he also said that forty percent plus of
the hospital emissions were people
non-vexed so you would look like yeah so
i've done the the calculations on that
as well
um
it's
maybe about 50 50 or something like that
so yeah definitely the vaccine certainly
produces self-protection for about the
first three months so you get your first
vaccine doesn't do much get your second
one you're actually really risky for the
first two weeks after your second
vaccine and you're more likely to get
all sorts of infections but then after
that you've got like a three-month
golden period where you have pretty good
protection for yourself against getting
severe
disease that then wanes
so definitely yeah of course um there
are less hospital admissions
but
in time that certainly does wane and if
you look at the israel numbers now it's
not doing much at all
just a final question you made some
reflection on
um some anti-vex people feel that
they've got worsening cancer situations
because of the vaccines and i just would
like some guidance on that because um
a lot of people that are in that health
compromised area are actually encouraged
to have the vaccine because they are
compromised yeah it's really tricky
because in the fisa's own documents and
the um
the data sheet and in the mid-safe risk
assessment it talks about the different
studies that have not been carried out
um
so personally in some of my own patients
with blood cancer the blood and this is
one that i could observe
because you can see blood cancers
changing quickly you can't do this with
other cancers and i had two of my own
patients the blood cancers got you know
quite a lot worse
um in the couple of months after the
vaccine and then they started settling
again which was great
um now this
i don't know what the studies are there
have been other international doctors
who have mentioned that they have seen
uh increases in endometrial cancer um
but it's just it's an area that we just
don't know the answers to like so many
areas
um so
it's it's yeah okay hard to know
thank you councillor sopa
thanks mr chair i just wanted to ask
either or both of the submitters
what the
um
reply would be to those
vulnerable and you know compromised
people who will feel that they are
unable to use
library pools hey rocketry
yeah
look i i think that i really feel for
those people um both of my parents are
over 70 and have medical conditions so i
understand
and
i think they need to know that they're
not
safe
going to the if there's areas of high
transmission regardless of whether the
people there are vaccinated or not
they're still not safe
looking at the numbers in auckland you
have uh just as many vaccinated people
with covert as you have unvaccinated
people with covet
so
and as the ministry of health said when
you've got high vaccination rates you're
more likely to get it from a vaccinated
person the other thing is if a
vaccinated person is more likely to be
asymptomatic because the vaccine has
reduced their symptoms then actually are
they more of a risk because if if an
unvaccinated person gets it and gets
lots of symptoms and feels like rubbish
and stays home taking vitamin c
they're not going to spread it if a
vaccinated person
gets it and has hardly any symptoms and
feels tickety-boo
they're going to be walking around with
just as high viral load and able to
speak it sing it all that kind of stuff
so i think for the vulnerable people and
when transmission is high when we're
actually in red
then they will want to probably be
isolating themselves anyway
i'd also encourage them to be getting
their vitamin d levels up something our
country is not talking about enough but
is incredibly useful
so there's many many things they can do
but
um i think that
whether unvaccinated people are excluded
or not isn't going to make much of a
difference
does that answer your question nikki did
you ever come in yeah
um i would just like to comment that
actually i'm in that vulnerable group
i'm extremely vulnerable to covert i've
spent a lot of time in intensive care
with respiratory disease i also have
autoimmune disease that is me and
i have to
you know my risk from covert is more
than just from the library it's going to
be
everywhere
it's you know i need to take
responsibility for myself and decide for
me what level of risk i'm willing to
accept and and
and do that wherever i go because it's
not just libraries and polls i mean it's
it kids are in school and mixing there's
churches there's other community places
there's the supermarket there's these
there's everywhere it's not just these
places and um everyone should be taking
personal
i might responsibility say that i'd also
say that they would probably want to get
themselves an n95 mask um so the
um the spread of the virus seems to be
largely through aerosols and the little
cloth masks we put on don't do much at
all
um as a doctor i have caught a cold
through a mask and the patient we were
both masked the patient tonight i caught
a cold
um so at that moment my faith in those
little blue masks went severely down
but i do have a lot of faith in the n95
mask so i think for the vulnerable um
being able to get a a well-fitted n95
mask is their absolute best form of
protection probably uh getting their
vitamin d levels up and um thinking
about some of those other preventers um
that we've talked about
that's cool
so as a double vexed immunocompromised
person over the age of 70
what is your advice to me stay home no
no i'd say enjoy life you don't want to
hide away for the rest of your life
because covet's here to stay um
i would say get your vitamin d levels up
get your vitamin d levels tested because
you want them over 70.
take vitamin d uh and once it's in the
community i'd be saying take zinc and
vitamin c and a little an extra nutrient
called quercetin which gets the zinc
into your cells um and when you've got
those things your uh
your risk drops dramatically and then
when you catch covert which you may well
still do as your immunity wanes get in
touch with me and i'll give you all the
other stuff
councillor pottinger
thank you look um it was fascinating
what you said about the transmission
rate between a vax and an unvax person
now in your opinion
with
the without the government painting the
picture
of the unvexed being the unclean and a
scourge of society would this whole
traffic light system and passport system
have any substance if you if you took
away
that
portrayal of the unvax being a problem
would any of this mandating have any
substance
i
i don't think it would have any
substance
i think
it makes no scientific sense to me at
all
and
the world looking at the world it's
managed the pandemic managed waves one
two and three of the pandemic over the
last
18 months or whatever um and a lot of
that they went through without vaccines
and um
uh
they managed with early treatments
there's a doctor shankara chitty who
works in south africa and he's worked
out um
how to treat covert uh through his own
patients and he's treated seven thousand
patients and not one has been admitted
to hospital
um so the rest of the world has done a
wonderful job with it and in new zealand
we've watched them and we're terrified
because we've been kind of safe and
we're watching it come towards us like a
tsunami and we're just so scared um so
yeah i don't think that answers your
question does it but i think you're
right
you did it's an interesting portrayal of
the unvaccinated and personally as an
unvaccinated person it's horrible to
feel the
the look on people's faces when they
realize you're unvaccinated you feel
horrible it makes you want to cry when
you realize that they look at you like
a lesser person and like a horrible like
a disgusting kind of person
no thank you for that appreciate it
thank you thank you councillors uh look
thanks sophie thank you nikki uh for
coming along and presenting today we
appreciate it and the questions that
you've been able to answer for the
councillors as well um i'll leave these
papers on the table thank you
councillors as a matter of process our
first step is actually to receive the
paper
the cover protection framework and
vaccine passports for council services
and facilities paper as a major late
item and i will so move if this is
secondary councillor evanson thank you
any discussion
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
against
kerry
for a start um before i give counsellors
the chance to
have their say make their statements
i will ask the chief executive to
introduce the report and also
acknowledge the presence
of the
executive leadership team
uh thank you for your input thus far and
your presence this afternoon clear thank
you mr chair look i want to remind all
counsellors
of the need to bring an open mind to the
discussion
in terms of predetermination it is
important that you don't
that you put those aside
thoughts that you may have had there
have been some comments in the media i
can't comment on social media but the
need is for you to come here today with
an open mind
this issue before you is not about staff
this is about public access it's not
about
staff access
and the report is going to be presented
to you by executive leadership team all
of whom are double vaxxed mr gibling
happens to be out of town and that's a
pity but he has a very able man in his
stead mr macquarie who will be able to
assist
and i'm sure that between all of us we
will be able to answer all of your
questions um i'll hand over to andrew
who i think has got a little
presentation to put it
in the right context
so
do you want to pull that mike and andrew
please
am i talking are you gonna walk i don't
talk the best at times um i think it's
important to start the consideration of
this by really
drawing back to the fundamentals i
suppose of what we're considering and
recognizing
our limitations i suppose is the real
point um
none of us are medical experts and and
you have a look at this in all the
government guidance and even when it
talks about it in the sense of a um
from a workplace health and safety
perspective it recognises that and says
look
none of us are experts on this
as much as we all sit on the couch and
think we might be we're actually not
and so we need to take uh lead from
people who have access to that expertise
that made decisions based on a lot of
advice that
ourselves as a council would struggle to
one be able to organize and to to be
fair to everyone here including myself
would struggle to actually be able to
interpret and apply
appropriately
and it's in that sort of context that
you look at
the guidance that has been given to
councils in the community through the
traffic light system
and so
it's important because everyone talks
about it and everyone talks about the
fact that they don't understand it but
it's important that we almost go back to
that as our starting point because
really what uh the decision that is
really being asked of council today is
do we follow the guidance in the traffic
light system that's been given by the
government or we do we for some reason
divert from that guidance because we
think we know better than what they're
telling us and that that really is a
crucial part of this discussion that you
need to understand because at the moment
the guidance that we have put out and
that was referred to early on from the
presenters
is following the guidance that we've
been given by the government
so we're going to talk through have a
look at that guidance make sure everyone
understands it and then just by our
background and then have a look at
specifically what that will mean for our
different facilities what it means if we
operate under that guidance if we want
to vary from that guidance the
implications for
effectively the levels of service that
we can provide to a community
so that's the sort of background that
i'm trying to give by this sort of uh
going through this process i'm just
trying to get back i don't think that's
at the beginning
yeah so effectively
what we're talking about is the code
protection framework everyone refers to
the traffic light so i will i apologize
that what i print out is black and white
so it doesn't really look like traffic
lights but but it's it's there
the reason why the government brought in
the traffic light or the cover
protection framework was for two reasons
to to minimize the impact on the
community and provide protection in the
community
and in reaching that decision and you'll
see there's a little bit more commentary
around it in the
the paper around the first and second
reading speech but it's important that
you recognize that in coming to those
positions the government took health
advice took legal advice around the um
the bill of rights it took into account
a whole heap of other factors and a
broad range of factors when reaching
this position
as to where it's trying to position the
community and the country
for living with covert as an endemic
disease i mean and that that's really
the starting point so
the government has considered
when setting these levels the protection
and the rights that everyone should have
taking into account a whole range of
factors and we can only sort of guess
what they are and i think i make the
note in the paper or it might have
fallen out it's disappointing that the
government won't release that until
january
but when that is released there will be
a lot of information that goes into this
and that has made it up and that
supports the reasons why they believe
the settings that are given to the
community are the best to minimize and
protect and that that's really where
we're starting from
just picking up claire claire's point
that the workplace health and safety
again it's important that you
distinguish these two things and you'll
see
you would have read in the press a lot
of councils are coming out saying oh
we're going to mandate this mandate and
then they'll come out today later or an
afternoon later and say oh but we still
haven't made a decision on staff
because they really are two separate
decisions
to a certain extent they may overlap
in that if you are for an example in an
event uh providing an event and you have
workers in the event then they will be
required to be vaccinated they'll be
required to wear masks they're controls
that are implied that we might have uh
in a council situation but would not be
mandated mandated but for an event
they're mandated so to a certain extent
it doesn't override the workplace health
and safety assessment but forces you as
an employer to imply certain controls
around your workplace health and safety
does that make sense but there but other
than that overlap where they might
address the same things they are
different assessments
that can be made
independently and are made independently
and so we've gone through the process
from a workplace health and safety
perspective and assess the risk to staff
but that is not really impacted well
it's not impacted by this uh process
here
so the other key thing and really is
crucial that really what drives the
whole process is determining what you
are under the traffic flight system what
are you
now
this is a list of the ones that apply to
areas that we are involved in but our
starting point for everything is that we
have a public facility
and we'll go through and have a look at
what that means on the traffic light
system but everything else underneath
that is really almost like a subset
in some circumstances we'll say we have
a public facility that is primarily used
for events therefore it makes sense that
we actually treat as an event space but
our starting point for all our
facilities would be that they're a
public facility
there was a bit of debate um because i
know it'll be a topical one but there
was a bit of debate about how swimming
pools were treated but the clear gardens
had come down the swimming pools are
public facilities
um now obviously if someone wants to
lease the swimming pool to have an event
or a gathering
then the event or gathering rules would
apply to that
but for the majority of its operation
the swimming pool is a public facility
and again
i put it up there and i'll repeat it
every time
the government in setting the rules was
setting those to minimize and protect
the community so the rules that they set
were the the the baseline that they
think are appropriate to minimise and
protect the community
just repeating what i said earlier once
once you've determined the activity the
rules around how you can operate under
that just flow it's pretty easy i mean
if we're a public facility
then it's pretty easy it only becomes
complicated where you've got hybrid
sites so if you and the little classic
one they use is obviously you've got a
library that has a a cafe in it
then you've got different sites if you
can't separate those different sites
then realistically you've got to take
the highest level of controls so in that
case you'd have to use it as a treated
as a cafe or you close the cafe
so you've got to try and manage and make
a call within them where you've got
these merged sites
but for us again we actually don't have
that many where a merged site causes a
problem
uh the other one to bear in mind you
cannot game the system i mean so for
instance the it's interesting and
people talk about uh later in the event
of the
impact on the facilities
for us you might look at it and say look
if we say that the the pool is an event
uh we can have more people at the pool
than we can as a
as a public facility the shorter entries
you can't no matter what we say in terms
of requirement for vaccine passes
whatever else we do at the pool it will
always be a public facility the capacity
will be limited by the settings for a
public facility
and you saw that uh i don't know whether
anyone did but there was a
cafe i can't remember where it was it
was up north somewhere that tried to do
that they said oh no we're not a cafe
where an event
and
funnily enough the government came out
and said no you're not you're a cafe um
you're an event if you leased it out to
an independent party but as long as the
owner is operating the facility you're a
cafe
um and so it's it's again it's common
sense you you can't play it the rules
once you get your head down they're
fairly clear but you've got it you're
stuck with what you get
so the only option we have and it comes
out if you have a look on the traffic
lights
it's mentioned every time under the
public facilities uh not in the not in
the the one that i printed out for you
but in the detailed one council has the
option to still
determine that it might want to use a
vaccine pass at those facilities
it's not mandatory it's not compulsory
it doesn't change any of the other
settings in terms of how many people can
be at the venue or what else we have to
do but we it specifically calls out the
facil the public facilities can
determine to do that as anyone can it's
uh it's hard to explain to people it's
just an additional control it's like um
if we said only people have radiant can
come into the council chambers
and it's just us setting rules for how
we can uh operate our business has
consequences
for the level of service that we provide
to people and and how we provide that
service which we explained a bit later
on but it's a decision that council can
make
but again i'm coming back to this point
the core point is
on what basis are we making and what are
we trying to achieve
because the traffic lights are aimed to
minimize and protect so what do we think
we're trying to achieve by doing
something beyond
what the government sets
as necessary to achieve those outcomes
the other thing that
really is and comes through very clearly
in the traffic lights is that public
facilities are treated very differently
it's clear that basically other than
green public facilities operate exactly
the same at orange or red
whether they use a vaccine passport or
they don't and so i mean you sort of
think yourself why when you look at the
business operations
um
they had a hobson's choice i mean they
could operate with or without a
a passport but the reality is to operate
you had to have a passport
now so that drove a behavior for events
and gatherings they had to go down this
path yet clearly there's been a
conscious decision by the government in
the background we're not going to force
public facilities to go down this path
in actual fact we're not even going to
make it any better for them if they do
we want them to be open and operating
but in operating at levels that we
haven't determined that minimize and
protect the community and they've made
that decision very clearly and set it
out in what they've done
as i said there's a lot in
the way this is presented that
his driving behaviors but you need to
have a look and look through it clearly
and see what questions are sort of
asking around those behaviors
um there's also a third subset obviously
and that will apply to some of our
facilities um
potentially uh the government's flag
that things like emergency housing will
not be able to ask for vaccine passports
so there are certain things certain
public core public sector provision of
services where the government is still
trying to finalize its position around
saying you actually can't ask for a
vaccine passport
oops
looks like you've got the end so i think
probably easiest now i mean i'll have to
answer any questions if you want um but
i suppose i'll get back to where i
started it's important that we
understand what we can make a decision
on and what we are in a position to
realistically make a decision on
um
if if we wanted some more advice on
things then then we can but there has
been
a lot of advice
received by the government in forming
these settings
if we wanted to change our settings
because we thought there was a health
reason why we should
i would probably urge on the caution of
saying we'll go and get some health
advice around it because i don't know
that despite the amount of information
that we've all absorbed on covert that
we're actually in a position to make
those calls we can all look at the
settings and say it's not what i do or i
don't see how that makes sense but that
doesn't make me
any better to make the decision than
anyone else
so if you just want to go through some
of the specific impacts on the
facilities
oh sorry so councillors if you can hold
off on your questions uh at the moment
we'll go through each of the facilities
then i'll give you a chance to ask
questions bearing in mind that there
will be questions we'll save the
points that you'd like to make till
later
and we'll do that after each facility if
is everybody comfortable with that
right do we need to counselor clerk no
i'm not comfortable with that there's a
couple things that andy raised that i
think are pertinent to what we're about
to decide so
we're not about to decide anything we
haven't finished listening yet okay
so
richard i think you've got the magic
talking stick
to everyone um
i just want to reiterate that no matter
what the decision or the outcome is of
today no matter what level of the
framework we're in
or setting wise or no matter whether we
ask for vaccine or vaccine uh not
we are and have always had the public
interest and health and safety protocols
in place at the forefront of our minds
so we will continue to
abide by the regulations but also ensure
that we are doing all those other things
like good mass good communications all
of those things so no matter what the
outcome is we are operating safely
within the guidelines that we've got
for the purposes of this we have focused
specifically on the operational
requirements of the business so we're
not taking in those wider things that
you're going to look at later on in your
debate we're looking at what does it
mean for the business to open day to day
and the sort of constraints under these
different levels under the different
scenarios so we'll start with splash
palace
and typically the same as with all of
our public facilities the capacity
limits do not change from level to level
vaccination or unvaccinated in the
general principle of allowing people
inside the building
okay
so apart from the civic which is in as
we've already talked about in the event
space so the splash palace remains at
the
thousand cap for people going through
that door and able to use that service
no matter where they are no matter what
vaccination certificate they're using
the difference comes
purely in the event space if they are
holding events or they have a third
party activity happening on the site
that may require a vaccination
certificate or limits on numbers
depending on uh whether it's classed as
an event or whether it's an external
hire privately etc the other impact of
course is on the cafe but of course
that's a supplementary service not core
business of um
the the space palace
that's splash pellets
do we want to stop after each one yes
any questions around splash palace
so i guess logic says then that splash
palace cafe is either closed
or requires passports
can you tell me which it is at the
present time
it's closed through you mr chair it's
actually uh running a contactless
service at the moment so right through
we can do contactless if
we need to and that kicks in
at the orange level so
without a vaccine
past checking it is a contactless
service
thank you i i guess no what i was going
to say is no question so i'll break
myself
the other questions around splash palace
counselor clark
just a confirmation i think i picked up
a comment before that
all the staff at
splash palace or double vexed
uh
councillor clark on mr chair uh my
comment would be that this is not an
opportunity to ask the vaccination
status of
staff by group
the paper reports that
uh we have identified those roles
where staff need to be double vaxxed
from a health and safety perspective
where our assessment is that there is a
risk that needs to be mitigated uh using
the questions that are provided by
workplace health and safety
that's as far as it would be appropriate
i'll accept that as an explanation
beyond that it's operational yeah okay
let's escape to that's
i did read
the document and even though it said
that there was no no limit on how many
people can be inside a public type
facility with capacity limits based on
one metre distancing does that apply
within the pool
as well through mr chair indeed it does
now this is this is some of the
ambiguity that is across the different
settings for the different types of
businesses
and i know particularly from our clients
everyone wants to know what happens
tomorrow and what is the answer and
we're all sort of you know intensely
trying to answer that we are living in
an evolving a situation an environment
that's it if our response is iterative
as well there are when you look closely
some anomalies across the different
types and classifications and we've
acknowledged that and i think that'll
get
tighter as time goes on but the
calculations based on the square
meterage of the building
and of those spaces available to
public and when you look at splash
palace actually it is a big building um
with a a lot of square meters and that
equals
actually more than what the fire
capacity limit is so some of our our
capacity at a thousand for splash palace
is actually the same as the um
fire rating so it has no material
difference of access because that also
applies to libraries and
correct centers in the whole lot yeah so
libraries stay at um 3 30 episode 413
all the way through
councilman lush
andrew just explained to me why um
in another
around the country a lot of the pulltown
libraries
are making it mandatory for vaccination
is that a different application that
they've done or a subtlety or what's the
discrepancy between councils well
through mr chair i think um the purpose
of local government is to apply a local
uh or regional lens to a solution rather
than a central mandate so the choice has
been given and i think it's up to each
individual community to respond in a way
that best meets their needs of the
community members so i don't think it's
a misinterpretation or
a change in interpretation it is simply
a choice that's been given to the local
authorities to make
also acknowledging that you know
auckland for example is coming out of
red and so
their body of knowledge that they're
holding on their shoulders is quite
different to what we may have down here
councillor sopa
thanks mr chair i'm just going back to
the question about the
splash palace cafe
could you just finish the door there so
at present with with no use of the
vaccine tasks it's a contactless service
use of the vaccine past then means
okay
three mischief yes so if they at orange
level if they instituted a vaccine
certificate to verification they will be
able to have a seated and served cafe so
again still scanning in
seated they can't wander around with
their food you can't have buffets and
things like that that season service can
operate at orange level
thank you
councillor skelt thank you for you
richard just a couple of questions first
one the best business practice decision
for the operation of special palace
would be under the under the traffic
light system as we have it would be what
uh
we are comfortable with the settings as
they are in terms of being
operationally implementable it's
it's following guidance and it's working
today there are no major concerns
as is
second question the best health and
safety decision for the community given
the government's guidelines
given given by the ministry of health
would be
how would we operate what would be the
best way to operate
uh three mischief i don't think there is
a golden answer in this if if there was
a golden answer that we knew was the the
right thing to do it would probably be
mandated so we've been given a choice
based on either options here
are safe are able to be implemented it
is our choice and and our role of course
and your role is to represent the
community views on that we don't we're
not scared by either version i think is
that the key thing so are you saying as
the group as
a consensus the best way to operate
given those two scenarios i've given you
would be to have
everyone double vaccinated is that what
you're saying
uh no i wasn't going that that far i was
saying we're comfortable with our
position as is and we will be equally
comfortable if the elected members chose
to use vaccinations certificate thank
you
councillor craig
thank you councillor ludlow
hello is that working yes
i think we've been really blessed that
we haven't had um covered in delta
ripped through the community like we
have um we're getting to a question
aren't we we are getting into a question
can we do so quickly
our country yep look
we've now railroad me now i've lost my
question are you gonna have to i'm gonna
have to come back sorry okay well it's a
good idea to start with it
any other questions around
splash palace
i'll let you come back to it when you
remember what's the next facility then
next facility we're going to look at is
the eve pool library the public library
all of what i've just described in terms
of those leveled and changed very
similar to the libraries so libraries
maintain their maximum capacity limits
again the biggest thing is that if
things get classed as events so the
events and programs are acknowledged to
go under that separate definition and
maybe more restrictive will be more
restrictive rather as we move up those
alert levels
um so specifically those are community
programs the great thing with the
library at the moment is the um
uh the
and i've forgotten the name of it but
the click and collect version of library
books is in place and there is more and
more e-resources being made each year so
it's beyond just the facility and the
the wall so we are lucky to have that
ability to have an online presence a
remote presence as well as the facility
itself
inviting questions one of the
issues with the library is um a large
number of entrances if if there was an
introduction of
vaccine certificates how would we cope
with i think four entries uh three three
public entries and one uh service entry
that's used and open for particular
events this goes across all of our
facilities
implementation of a vaccine certificate
verification service will have an impact
on and will be discussed a little bit
later in finance but will have an impact
on staffing levels the types of staff
that we employ and ask to do that job
and where they're situated with the
library we've got a very clear d street
entrance which is very visible open and
sight line of the front counter but also
two entrances off the car park that are
a little bit out of the way that are
a far more uh confined space so if there
is an altercation or any sort of
education conversation that gets heated
it's a little bit um enclosed and
further and might require us to look at
resources such as security rather than
staffing it with regular staff so yes in
in across all of our facilities
verification does come with added
investment in it as well as a workforce
implication
council amundsen thanks um the submitter
before mentioned that some of the
activities and stuff have not been
operating in the library and i notice in
the
um
list of things on page seven around a
vaccine certificates are not used that
events and programs and gatherings would
likely be affected but there's nothing
um i guess to
uh
in the if vaccine certificates are used
would those things come back
through mr i think that's the million
dollar question that and all of us are
asking ourselves we're trying to compare
the future with what was normal and we
to a certain extent we have to release
what was normal because it may not be
that benchmark able to be you know
when are we going to recover we don't
know there's still hesitancy about
coming back we've probably been being
quite cautious about the programs that
we do offer because we're trying to find
our space and how we're going to operate
in this new world
um i'll invite marianne to answer the
question about programs if i possibly
could she's yep
she's just going to come and grab that
microphone
we are
trying some remote programs as well so
we aren't continuing with our progress a
lot of those
are done as an outreach and we're also
providing some programs where
families can take work in a bubble and
come in i think the program is
so just to clarify the loss of those
programs that's been mentioned by the
submitter is not a result of the traffic
light system
it's been like that since covert began
councillor clark then councillor scout
yeah richard just on the issue of the
multiple entry points
um
is it possible to
restrict the two
off-car park security
entryways
three missed chair i think yes um
whatever facility we want we want there
are barriers to accessing our facilities
and one of the barriers is car parking
so to block that off does actually
restrict a lot of usage and becomes
another barrier about why people might
visit a facility so certainly our aim
would be and our desire would be to keep
all the entrances open
i also want to acknowledge at this point
in time that we are not quite sure what
the next six months hold in terms of
technology solutions so at the moment
we're taking a if we go down vaccine
certificate verification it will start
with just simply citing it will move to
to phones but in six months time there
might be other
alternative technology and one of the
things we've seen in the united states
is the higher use of turn style
facilities where you can step back from
that person and still see a green light
etc so we would have to wait to the
market catches up with that
but our principal thing would be to keep
as many
access points to the library open as
possible so just one question to follow
up to that uh i had a look at those two
off car parks today
is it possible that uh that could be
reduced down to one now way to do that
could be that it's exit only so you turn
off the sensor on the outside of the
door so nobody can come in on the second
floor which is quite an isolated area
but they could come in on the ground
floor of the car park be directed down
and come in
but exit wise for fire service they
could still go out three minutes chairs
certainly with whatever gets decided
here today we will work through the
operational requirements and i'm going
to get bogged down today about
about those things at a management level
but we certainly we're happy to try
things we're happy to be iterative with
our response
and live in this ambiguous world for a
little bit while so yeah we would have
quite happily trial things as
appropriate thank you councillor cracker
thank you um
now i am going
to get a good question out and i'm not
expressing an opinion so please mr chair
do entertain my
dribble
uh when our
people in our community become sick
because i i guess it's a little bit of a
degree i feel of complacency at the
moment with
us not having it here and for such a
long
time
do we have the ability at any point to
change our mind
if the risk profile increases so or
could we take a staged approach
to when we implement a
mandated vaccine pass
at x point we could decide a break point
of when the risk to the community is too
great
three mischief i think that's a really
good point
remember the traffic light system allows
for an increase in a change of operation
environment and that's why we would
naturally move up from a green to an
amber to a red so it's got that built in
but at any stage if we felt that we were
out of step with the community views or
we felt that the risk profile had
specifically changed within this
environment of course i think we would
want to be able to have a conversation
again so
we are not asking for an all and
eternity solution here we have to
acknowledge that there will always be
iterative response
okay just so everybody's up to speed
with my question list i'll be going to
councillor scout and mrs coach then
councillor pottinger
thank you to you just two questions
richard just the demographic of the most
used
sorry the user of the facility the
library at this prison point in time
would be age group wise
if fight through mischief i answered
that it would be purely my speculation
and personal opinion i think i'll refer
to uh
marianne you want to take your best
guess
uh young families and older over 60s and
could you give me a split on what would
be the greater of the two
they're probably about equal i would say
and
perhaps through either the group could
you give me a opinion on who may be then
medically the most vulnerable i don't
think that that group
because we have some medical experts
with us no it varies from person to
person
every individual is do so i'm saying no
to the question sorry
i don't i don't think anybody here has
an ability to answer
android
that
comic
yeah my only comment would be that
inherent in the system they've been
presented with is those calculations
if we if we're going to make if there is
a need to make rules for
parts of the demographic then the system
we were presented with would have that
inbuilt the fact that it doesn't
inherently they've taken that into
consideration we could go down that path
and that's what i'm saying if you want
to go down and have a look at those sort
of points for your decision making you'd
have to get some specific advice on it
but those
calculations are inherent in the model
thank you that's where i was leading to
thanks this is scoot
um i do understand that um we may need
to apply like different roles in
different phases and when
sorry
and my question is regards to the
technology and the changes that may have
tech happen if we apply the my vaccine
plus verification
it's quite interesting that we're a wee
bit behind because cafes bars and
restaurants had to apply that straight
off within
like 24 hours
and um
i know many sort of just got a cheap
phone downloaded the app and and it's
been
been used successfully so i mean when
when we're considering cost and
technology i think
there's no barrier there because it's
doable
um
so yeah so that would be my sort of
position with the you know not looking
for your position pioneer i'm looking
for your question so my question would
be
you're really pushing the limit here if
we're actually um
going to apply any any my vaccine paths
with any of our places that we're going
to discuss today
what would be the time frames around
that
three missed chairs in fact we've
already got one with events and the
civic of course cannot operate
practically without the my vaccine pass
so we are starting with um just visual
checks and then phones the interesting
things is the guidance from business.gov
says that uh
you must if you're going to just cite
them then you must do random checks to
verify and it has it said that they'll
come back with details about what that
percentage is and where we get to
understand that and we we know that
there are some ticketing companies that
are integration at the back end as well
so starting with citing but that's
actually probably quite good in terms of
the iterative response and enforcement
of government on are we doing the job
right and also allowing our communities
some opportunity to to make mistakes and
have conversations with them about how
to improve
um
we know that supply is a bit of an issue
for phones but yes we do have access to
a limited stock of phones to be able to
do that and if the decision today was
made to use vaccine certificates we
would be able to
move on that in an appropriate um time
frame
we could make it work and so my other
question would be you know because we
need to provide a service for those that
are not vaccinated in some way well
you know
what what would that look like or what
what could that be like
through mr chair i think um
we know that the the digital journey for
our community has accelerated through
the last couple of years in terms of
online transactions and accessing online
services and to a certain extent
that has caught a lot of parts of the
world um you know a little bit earlier
than what we were hoping to have and a
little bit earlier than perhaps some of
the technology available we are always
working towards going more online for
our services and providing that
democratic balance between online and in
person it just might mean that if we go
down the vaccine certificate checking
pathway that we need to accelerate that
and focus some more energy on that
certainly
the libraries have the ability to
already do some outreach and some
digital stuff but that might change the
profile about how we invest in our
library stock so we might look at more
uh to build that um ee
asset base as well
thank you
councillor arnold i need to be excused
mr chairman
thanks counselor partner
thank you look this question is related
to uh the question about whether a
facility could change its status
midstream
and my question is and and i know the
tears gonna get angry with this were you
aware
that yesterday nelson changed
its status from no passport to a
passport when community cases became
prevalent
were you aware of that
would the chair let me dance there it's
a closed question so you can give one or
two responses
no
right there we go then my answer that
was after
councillor scout is it a question it is
sir
uh richard through your vast experience
in the event industry and i understand
that you're running some events at civic
theater
are you or is the public
somewhat confused
at the current state of
where venues within the invercargill are
currently operating is there a level of
tension
fear
intimidation
any of those factors one or all
currently
that we may like to consider in making a
decision later on
through mr chair all of those traits are
the characteristics of change
so i think
yes would be to every single one just
the same as
when we introduce compulsory
um
helmets on bikes seat belt laws
whatever change brings always brings a
certain amount of anxiety and does
settle down my experience in the venue
space doing events in the weekend
a range of response
interestingly enough um anecdotally the
the older
age group all presented their past as
beautifully laminated from the warehouse
and
very well organized and actually the the
younger people were those struggling uh
with um
the uh having things ready and what they
needed to do so there is confusion and i
think that's where there is benefit
and acknowledging that not only can we
make a decision today but we need to
provide a little bit of space for
communication and invest in those common
strategies so everyone knows what to
expect
prior to going to a facility so they're
not having that awkward conversation
with the person at the door or the
person at front counter
we knew need to invest in our comms and
clear messaging
so the second part of the question was
in your vast experience and knowledge in
the event industry
would it be
in your opinion
advan advantages to be consistent across
all the venues that is the council and
any other venue so that our community
um can walk and talk
and relate and interact with dancing
along a fine line of conflict there
counsellor i'm asking you can stop me by
all means but i'll ask someone who's
very learned over there if you could
give me a response stand there through
mr chair uh
it would be lovely if all of our
decisions could be universally applied
and understood by a community and that
will never happen it will also never
happen to assume that all community
members are accessing the same uh
facilities yes there is an advantage in
ensuring that we are in step with like
facilities so i do believe that there is
an advantage of
close libraries who have a reciprocal
agreement with each other that they are
operating in a similar way yes
for venues operation and similar
spaces it would be lovely to think that
they were the same but a blanket rule
across
all council facilities is probably not
going to deliver the same message
there's still going to be nuances that
will confuse people
thank you thanks just with regards to
the library and the question
earlier about
possibly closing off
some of the access points does that
create a risk around
the fire code
three mischief or two years did you
rather um
the
whatever we did would be about
restricting public access of fire egress
and would all have to still maintain so
that'd be still be crash doors or
whatever to to get out or be on a
maglock system we're simply talking
about do we check people at that time at
that particular door or entry point
thank you
any other questions counselors around
the library
next on the conveyor belt next we've got
uh um hey wakatuia
this is an interesting
one because we've got a very small space
so actually again capacity numbers don't
materially change
hugely between their fire occupancy
levels and the restrictions placed on um
the different uh
vax or novak's different amber green red
etc settings the main difference here
again
is uh about
uh our programs and our things when we
are coming together now the interesting
thing with the rocketeer is school
groups and external parties coming
through will of course always have their
own policy to adhere to just like a
private group or a retirement home etc
so again no material differences going
through
um
the different levels apart from the the
need to implement a vaccine attack and
and checking facility
in haywa katuya that's quite easy
because you've got a one single entrance
and you do have a reception right by
that door as you go in so it's an easier
one to implement
sorry miss cop
through you mr chair um hiwaka toya is
whilst it is classified as a museum and
art gallery space it also is a private
event space so therefore
could it be
that a hirer could
exempt people from passes even should we
make it
a vaccine path facility
three mr chair you can have facilities
that switch between the two so that's
what we're suggesting with the scottish
hall where it becomes the event
organizer
there are and of course with the civic
we've got
a vaccination clinic in the front so
obviously they can't be double vexed
because they'll be very quiet
but we do have an auditorium that
requires double vaccination we can't
operate at the same time and we require
an added level of shutdown and clean
between those two modes so it is
feasible to run a facility with a double
fax passport system
and then have a private hire that they
make the decision on and provided there
is
space it's not happening at the same
time and it
has a reasonable and responsible level
of cleaning between the two events
um a supplementary question to that
it's a space i know very well it comes
as no surprise to anybody here i am
concerned how small the space is and
the
the perhaps increased or the perception
of increased
risk factor
for people
um sharing space with those
that may potentially
taking the point that was made earlier
that we don't know who is carrying virus
or not but the extra risk that comes
with
such a small space are we leading to a
question well i wonder mr chair what we
should be thinking about in terms of
hewakatui because of the size and i
wondered whether that was a risk factor
that we were considering when we are
looking at what we do at iwakitaya
through mr chair certainly the traffic
light system and the the nuances between
the different types of facilities do
take into account
air space and air flow so that is a
factor which is why
bigger buildings are you know can have
more people and there's a different
profile for outside events versus inside
if the decision was made
and and we were concerned at a
operational level about the health and
safety of that site we would do a
regular health and safety
um assessment which may include looking
at the hvac systems there are uh
solutions in hvac to install at cost
uv filters that do kill the circulation
of air so
there are options out there there are
also freestanding options that we did a
bit of investigation into so if a
decision was made then we were then
worried or concerned about that
stuffiness or the air flow there are
some practical solutions that are
available um expensive but but still
potentially um doable
thank you for your tolerance mr chair
councillor amundsen
thanks just going back to the event side
of things i guess for hiwaka toyo i know
that they haven't had any opening events
for any of the exhibitions for
ever
um
if um
if we did or did not bring back vaccine
or bring in vaccine certificates under
orange or red would they potentially be
able to recommence
through mr chair that's a really
interesting one and i think this is one
of the nuances that is going to be
um talked about in the coming months
because for
those sorts of events that you might
class as a cocktail function or where
you go to a bar and you pick up a wine
technically even using vaccine passes at
orange upwards it has to be a seated
service so you have to take your glass
of wine and find somewhere quiet and sip
it by yourself
that's probably not the experience
you're wanting for openings and or
for your space of shows etc so it might
just mean a change in how openings are
done
but regardless of the alert alert level
or the vaccine or no vaccine you're
still able to have um gatherings inside
so there's
at the occupancy level which is around
100 so that's still doable
it just might look different this is
coot
so just in regards to that to my
understanding
with those types of nightclubs and
gatherings and type things that
businesses can operate with none but
limits but uh without numbered limits
but
face coverings also encouraged
so there is i'm just saying different
roles of different things and it's just
quite interesting you just
respond
and i think that's one of the things
you've got to look at because that point
i was trying to make earlier and if the
event was being run by someone other
than council yeah then it would be an
event run under the event
but if it was an event been run by
council it would operate under the
public facility rules
that's and that's that's what i say in
terms of gaming the system that was what
that cafe was trying to do
if we run an event it's under the public
facility rules if someone else runs an
event so hence why the theater works
because we don't actually we lease the
theater to the party that's all that
that's having the
show there um but if we were doing it
ourselves then it would be under public
facility rules
just uh supplementary to to give some
clarity on that one too because of the
size of hayward couturier it's not a lot
of difference so if we look at the fire
capacity at 118 it might be reduced down
to an event that can only have 100 but
that's probably not a material impact in
terms of
possibly there's only 60 to 70 people
there on average anyway for an opening
councillor lewis thanks mike it sound
pedantic
civic theatre
two separate entertainment areas the
room on the left an auditorium two
different events or
there will be a certain amount of
co-mingling with the public toilet or
the toilet facilities how would that be
dealt with through mr chair they cannot
run simultaneously
so there has to be separation of time
and air flow
we do have separation of airflow but
those co-mangling spaces the toilets and
the central concourse area we we cannot
separate um as with everything no matter
what we choose
face coverings will be encouraged inside
and so it might be once people are
seated they can take it off but in those
public spaces we will still be
encouraging good good measures about
washing hands keeping the distance and
wearing a face mask but we won't
co-mingle the two types of events
anything else under hawakituya
okay
next one we move on to is the cemetery
and uh crematorium chapel and services
so we've excluded the open space of
parks and reserves for obvious reasons
it's a lot simpler being outside and
it's
it doesn't have controlled entrances but
here we're looking at a facility
which is a public facility but used
largely for private
hires so again what we just talked about
like with scottish hall it's the hirer
who chooses so in other words you might
have a
a
um
a funeral that
the family decide they want to have
unvaxed and vax people there that would
be their choice within the um hire is
basically the funeral director so they
wouldn't limit it to 50. but equally
that family could say actually we want
100 people here and we've checked we're
going to enforce and we're going to be
responsible for that enforcement and
have it as a double-backed
event but again that's on the event not
the venue itself
just anecdotally to give you a bit of
um and so i had an inquiry from a woman
who's having a wedding um
on the 18th of december and she rang
last week to see if we could accommodate
them and the the reason was that they
were all double facts but they're booked
into a venue that wasn't requiring
double vaccine and so therefore they had
to limit a church they had to limit
their
their crowd and um so they were trying
to find
another solution very quickly for a
wedding and so no matter which way you
go there's going to be people that get
disadvantaged
questions around chapters
it's a really good microphone
um
civic edmund building
i'll hand over to my colleague now
yoda koto so as you're probably aware
our civic uh administration building on
the ground floor we at reception we
offer a channel a face-to-face service
for customers mainly it's to take
payments whether that be rates or
for dog registration or parking fines or
infringements of other kinds
but also we offer advice and
an enquiry service for people wanting to
talk through something or they might be
wanting to lodge a rates rebate or they
may be wanting a
request for service loaded in person
rather than over the phone
we offer property file viewing as well
and
often our staff are acting as
receptionists for either coming to
meetings in this space or to
meet with other staff so they might have
a licensing
interview for example
so we have found
over the since we returned at level two
that already over twenty percent of the
customers coming into our
uh center have not got a contact tracing
app so we're manually recording
their details at the moment
the majority of customers using our
face-to-face service do prefer
that to phone or online because they may
struggle
for various reasons whether they have
access to the technology or they
struggle with hearing or they just
prefer to see someone in person
so we have put in extra measures to
protect our staff and our customers such
as appropriate mask wearing you'll find
that your concierge through
our service and we also have cleaning
operating throughout the day
and that's been working really well
so if we were to make a decision on or
as you'll make a decision if we were to
go to a vaccination path system that
would mean that we would need to an
extra triage point as you go through but
also it's getting our customers to
embrace our online capabilities or our
phone services if they're unable to
enter the premises
then obviously uh how does that impact
on people wanting to pay cash
it's not oh through you mr chair it's
not just cash it's fpos as well so
that does impact that they would need to
work with their financial services
provider to find
a direct debit direct credit or online
payment
questions around the civic
administration building ground floor
first floor and meeting rooms
staff are looking at me saying gosh who
made the contribution and the report to
this particular area and i have to
confess i did
look as you can see it operates on the
basis of one metre between elected
members between staff limiting the
number of people in the public gallery
with two metre space between them
again
it's your call
uh the point that's made in the report
that it could disadvantage those without
access to technology if they wish to
participate particularly as we go into
an election year if they wish to
participate in the democratic process
particularly if the library also
required vaccination certificates um
trudy's referred to the 20
um and
this is where it starts to back up in
terms of impact from one place to
another
councilor lush then councillor keith if
it came vaccine
a vaccine passport area how would that
affect councillors that were not
vaccinated would they
would they just have to attend by
zoom there would be a choice for them to
attend by zone uh you have received
legal advice from
lgnz i'm going to start looking at
andrew because actually this is where it
gets really
complex in the sense that just because
you require a vaccine certificate in an
area
does not mean that staff
have to be double vaxxed in that area
and that is written in the legislation
that is council's own staff
councillors aren't staff and similarly
we are unable to impose
uh because in fact they are independent
contractors so i did have another look
at the
legal advice that was received earlier
but andrew has the degree i think
simplistically it's not it's something
you can do i suppose it's the first
point um and it doesn't stop the
council of
conducting completing their their duties
by zoom or otherwise
as long as uh i'll put the one right
around as long as the legislation
continues to allow that to occur
because that particularly the zoom
meetings was a covert 19 adjustment but
presumably that will stay into the
future
councilor q
yeah thank you chairman
[Music]
question number one
are all our elected members double faxed
don't think that relates to the issue
well i think it does well i'm saying it
doesn't
well i want an answer please well you're
about to be very disappointed
so i don't think understanding orders i
can require anything and that's my
ruling
you can't require people to disclose
that personal information why not
i think fantastic proceeds
yeah um there are matters of privacy and
we're actually discussing vaccination
passports for buildings so the
vaccination status of counsellors is
actually irrelevant
and i'm not debating it further
do you well i don't
sorry no because i well i understand
that you want to know but as i said
earlier on you're about to be very
disappointed
because i'm not going to sit here and
require all counsellors to reveal their
personal vaccination status
and i know and i'm giving you a simple
ruling as chair
that you can't ask that question
i don't agree with you
i'm sorry but you're not cheering the
procedure
i understand i understand that you want
to ask it but
actually you don't have the right to
well i've got very good reasons why i
need an answer well
there are many of us who have various
concerns yes you worship
point of order
one response to a point of order yes
sorry i want to hear your point of order
you worship what was it sorry i think
counselor cares is quite
able
to ask a question
and what would your suggestion be if
somebody didn't want to answer
well that's their choice yep
council clerk might be able to help with
this
i approached
this issue with the privacy commission
about six weeks ago
he said an organization can ask its
staff and be mindful this is counsellors
so the issue will be who does the asking
can ask staff
where they are vexed
staff have the right as counselors do
to decline to comment
the organization then has the right to
assume
that those people who declined to
comment
are non-vexed and treat them accordingly
so the issue is not do we expose people
at this meeting which i wouldn't be in
favor of because there are privacy
issues
but somebody in our organization at the
governance level
needs to go around individually and
assess
the
status of each counsellor so
coming back to the point that i i agree
with your point coming back to what i
said earlier on it's not actually
relevant to the issue that we're
discussing which is the protection
framework framework and vaccine
passports for council services which is
why i've said no to the question there
will be another process that you can ask
it through but it's not this one today
um can i speak
councillor abbott
i'm just i want to say back to standing
orders if the chairman makes a ruling
there is no debate thereafter yes
i'm being a little lenient
because i can sense the frustration at
my ruling
however i'm going to move on
mrs coote okay
um i understand you cannot ask or to
provide your vaccine pass to exit basic
services such as supermarkets public
transports and sexual health services
and i read that you were exploring that
for the blood
i was just wondering is that being a
supporter
we will come to it oh okay no i was
meaning is it being at school we're
still on the first
floor here in meeting venues but bluffs
up next
so any other quiz sorry peter i know you
had you said you had a couple of
questions so was there anything apart
from the vaccination status of
counsellors that you wanted to ask
question number two thank you
are our appointees
same situation
same situation final ruling any other
questions you'd like to ask
those issues but i'll bring it up if
it's got to come through the media it
will be through the media but
and i'll remind you of the council code
that we've just spent an enormous amount
of money
on behalf of the ratepayer in developing
thank you any other questions about the
first floor meeting area
sorry councillor scott i just want you
to help me just about the cross
pollination from floor to floor from
first floor down to ground floor
interaction with unvex and vaxxed
downstairs is there is there a lot of
cross-pollination or help me
through you mr chair so in terms of just
for clarification
are you meaning staff mixing yes
with the public with the public not not
easily as easily downstairs it's secured
for example
and
that we know
when our staff have meetings with
members of the public should it be for a
licensing manager's certificate or such
like all that's recorded in diary so
when you ass when you're
we know who we've met and we know where
they've been and they are wearing masks
through when they're coming through we
only have two people in a lift at the
same time etc
and they don't come to our desk areas or
anything like that but
by and large the majority of
transactions where the public enter the
building are completed and resolved on
the ground floor
so the short answer that there is
cross-pollination
uh claire can you add um i can't just
help me yeah mr chair i was going to add
to it to say that prior to
the last lockdown there was a practice
of a lot of staff coming into the
building through the customer service
centre and some would leave through
through the customer service centre the
staff on the ground floor now would
complain that they do not see staff who
are entering and leaving the building
because they are using the rear door
that's a big help thank you
anything else on the first floor
right now we come to bluff
so through you mr chair the bluff
service center is a little different in
that it offers council library services
plus also lotto new zealand post and
kiwi bank
we the advice we've had to date and at
the time of writing was that we're the
host for the kiwi bank and lotto
facilities and so whatever is decided uh
will be what is undertaken so if that's
a vaccine pass that will happen if not
they're fine either way in terms of new
zealand post that has a little bit of
difference they advised us late last
week that they were working with mb to
see if they defined as what's classified
as an essential service like a
supermarket or a petrol station
if that was the case we could not
enforce a vaccine pass for
customers to enter that site however you
could close and restrict your council
and
library facilities if that was what you
wanted
but that would reduce
well take out that part of the service
it would make it tough going the
capacity limit for bluff is about four
customers
so it is a small and unusual building
with them so
just being cognizant of that very
special people it is a very special
service
are there concerns
with
the safety for staff who are interacting
in that space
to you mr chair our staff are really
confident with using
the tools we have in place now such as
we're concierging down there they have
great screens and things like that that
perspex screens in place
sanitizer
one meter the distancing rules
everything like that so uh to my
knowledge there has not been any issues
in that space thank you councilor lush
is uh possible to have the library at a
stage where it's just vaccine only and
the rest of the area is
is there room to do that
admin
anything is possible but you'd have
you would need to have a triage point at
the front too but you're actually going
through
to the back and then you'd have to have
another triage point to um prevent so it
may have some additional staffing costs
but uh other than that a supplementary
question is there an alternative
entrance to the library not that would
be appropriate to use so there's
obviously a fire exit but that's not um
conducive to
using as a public entrance
thank you
councillor clay just a quick reflection
um in recent times government has
decreed that new zealand post is an
essential
business
thank you
councillor lewis thanks mr chair just a
quick question may i have a commute a
definitive decision
when it comes to the council chamber on
such committees as creative communities
will be in which which have
public members in that
make up
clear
the the short entries they'll be
operating under whatever decisions at
the moment it's a public facility there
would be a gathering in a public
facility
and would operate under those rules if
you added another layer of vaccine
passport then the people on that
committee would have to meet that
requirement as well
although i mean as we've discussed you
could alternate between the two but i
think to the point of certain that you
don't want to be swapping if you can if
you can help but you want to have a rule
that applies at all times
my point thank you very much
which i think leaves the
animal control facility
[Music]
oh sorry
i thought we'd bluff it out there we go
it's part two of bluff
did you want to come
so
as you'll see we have the bluff
community board meetings at the
municipal chambers uh
we would need to have obviously a
resource there and similar to here if we
were to have that that the online
channel would need to operate
uh for
the
either elected members or members of the
public to interact
in that space so it's a similar
outcome to what would happen with
chambers
the differences i understand there's not
the
connectivity
that we have available in this chambers
by comparison
yet
thank you
questions about the bluff municipal
chamber
animal control
so the animal control or care facility
is where we only have an interaction
with the public if they have been to pay
their infringements
at
the building here and they're going down
to collect their animal
we cannot restrict
contact altogether obviously to hand to
hand an animal over to an owner but we
take all the precautionary measures with
ppe etc and it is uh by appointment only
so we know the person's coming we are
prepared and can manage the situation
but it's a restricted access facility no
members of the public are usually what
should be in there that we have um
significant
uh security controls in place
in that space
thank you
have i missed any spaces
if not councillors it's your last chance
for questions of staff around any of the
facilities councillor partner
um my question is question is from
andrew who introduced
the um
the subject so it's not to do with any
facilities but
it's actually andrew started off um
using the words we are
operating on guidance from the
government and now
this is what i'm struggling with having
done a 12-month dance with the three
waters
and every fact
that we've contested and the statements
they've made have been false i mean i
don't want to read them out but i have
three clear ones i'm not going to go
there
but why
why
are we relying on guidance from the
government when it's proven
that
yes it isn't that clever i mean
seriously
um you know
this is this is not a joke we have just
done the three water thing and it's been
a disaster and factually so many things
were incorrect yet we have to listen to
them and the key element
that is running this thing and dr sophie
touched on it
is that the unvacs
are the walking unclean and need to be
prevented and that is what this council
is going to decide on now
um i really appreciate doc there's a
question coming isn't it it is it is and
i'm saying so why
why should we
rely on guidance from the government
we'll leave that one to the lawyer
simplistically what you're complying
with is your mandatory obligations what
you are considering is whether or not
you vary from those mandatory
obligations you have no
choice but to comply with the law as
it's written
the decision that you're considering is
whether to go beyond what the government
requires
so again back to that point be very
clear
you are making the decision yourself if
you go down a path other than what we
are currently doing
and we're legally allowed to
we can sit
as the owner of premises you can make
the rules around access to those
premises that michael will touch on some
of the issues that raises but
i'll let michael do that and then i'll
come to council o'clock
thank you councillor
through yourself the chair
there are a few other facilities that we
haven't touched on which are the open
spaces facilities um that we have like
transfer station recycling drop-offs and
public toilets etc
um we've not brought those up because
it's impractical in relation to the
mandatory requirement relation to those
the other aspect is around our lease
facilities
that's where there is uh a council-owned
property that we lease out once it's
leased it becomes the responsibility of
the lease or to loudly see sorry my
apologies
in relation to setting those controls in
relation to that facility
so i just want to bring those ones up
i have the
pleasure of not being a health expert
and and giving you
advice around your finance and risk
which i think in relation to that um
gives gives a
a bit of a challenge in some of those
respects
uh a good indication of where um
of the finance side is you've got a
traffic light paperwork in front of you
which is in black and white
um
that is because i changed all the
printers and the shades are great
cost saving me it was a cost saving
exercise
look
one of the key aspects that we need to
take into account is the cost of service
but also i want to touch on around
funding aspect in relation to those
services because it may impact on some
of the facilities as we as i go through
those and discuss that with you
so we've touched on the increased costs
we've already had increased costs in
relation to covert and putting in
protection measures
in relation to the health and safety
requirements that we've had to comply
with
you've heard those mentioned screens
contributes um etc
for a mandatory vaccination of our
facilities there will be an increase in
cost in relation to those that are not
within our budgeted
ltp
the costs have been indicated in a
number of spaces around increased
staffing to man those resources uh those
particular access points and those
access points if you've been to any of
the facilities that have got mandatory
requirements there is one full-time
resource that's sitting there having to
do that
the other aspect that's been touched on
is our technology in relation to rolling
that out
yes we can roll some of that technology
out now um having said that we are very
limited covert has brought on a supply
chain issue that we are
in the same market as everyone else
trying to get this equipment in relation
to having the technology available
and that technology is limited we can
use what we've got available at the
moment but if
we required any increase in that we
would be very stretched to get that
technology in quickly
the other aspect you need to take into
account with your cost of service is the
drop in patronage
you will have aspects in relation to
that this will where we will be looking
at a drop in the service with the number
of people that are going through in
either scenario
we have not modeled that at this point
but i wanted to bring that to your
attention that that needs to be
considered for each of these facilities
the other side i talked to wanted to
talk about was the funding aspect in
relation to this
i wanted to take away
one of the aspects which is around the
a lot of the facilities are paid for by
your general rates now one of the
aspects with a general rate is it is a
a rate on the property and it is a
provision of the service
it is up to council to define how they
provide that service um so it could be
via facility could be through the um a
drop-in etc but it needs to be clearly
defined to the public
there are well there is one facility
there is a
direct um charge in relation to a
service and that comes to the bluff
community charge i wanted to draw that
council's attention that is a direct
charge to the bluff community for those
facilities in that service so i just
wanted to bring that one
there is no other at this point direct
charge to facilities we own each other
the only other direct charges we have
around our three water facilities
and our
solid waste
service
probably pause there for questions um i
do want to just check if we want to go
through the six recommendations after
that but i'll pause the questions around
funding and financing ah we'll get to
that later councillor clark yes two or
three questions um
when you talk about it upgrades
are you referring just to
duty staff having scanners with an app
on it or are you going beyond that
i'm not going beyond that at this point
councillor uh what i'm talking about is
the ability to get those those phones
and that technology for the frontline
staff okay pretty much all of our rit
equipment at the moment is utilized
there's a
the odd one or two that we could um
streamline out but we would be limited
on the issue of dropping drop in service
which is patronage i guess
when you go to do your modelling will
you be looking at the reverse of what
you're suggesting so
the suggestion is if we have passports
there'll be some drop in service but
there could be potentially
that's what i'd like your opinion on a
drop in service if we didn't have
passports
to yourself the chair look that is not
something i
can provide advice on that's that's a
personal choice in relation to the
public whether they do or don't access
that from that perspective yep and the
last one was the general rates and i
understand the need for generates to
deliver service i get that
and certainly the library's got some
alternatives there
but how would you expect
given that we face a pandemic how would
you expect a pool to have an alternative
delivery
to the core service
through yourself the chair a paul
at the service that's provided in in the
pool is mainly
user pays
service
the facility itself it's not
at this stage
from perspective of
the general rates it is very clear under
the legislation that it is
a provision for
service and not a direct charge for
service under a general rate if it had
been a specific rate
for those services
then yes there would be a concern an
issue in relation to it thank you
councillor scout thank you for your
chance through michael's point about
finance and increased costs just richard
among if you could help me
around events and management do you
perceive that
the existing staff and the venues may be
able to take up those
roles initially to may help with that
process or do you believe that we would
have to increase staffing levels
over a period of time or how do you
perceive that just given the current
state of affairs three mr chair um it's
a fairly easy one for us we've got
luxury of being mandated and basically
have to use a vaccine certificate
verification service
we had a conversation early on and
thought that actually the technology and
that infrastructure was our
responsibility as a venue but we already
charged our client
for front of house services and we
consider this a cost of doing business
so the extra front of house staff will
be passed on to the client
we have yet to make a determination
whether it's appropriate or not for that
vaccination checking person to be a
staff member or whether we just monitor
and it should actually be a security
person we're undecided on that and we're
just going to take a really close
monitoring approach but it will be
passed on to the
client so it won't actually impact an
fte
or rates funded impact and would that be
the same for splash palace and that same
working space
through this gear obviously the splash
palace doesn't have the ability to on
charge that service so that and it also
operates under the fees and charges so
if we wanted to adjust
our fees and charges to do some cost
recovery then that would be through the
normal ap process but at this stage it
would be an extra
burden on the on the business to fund
that thank you
councillor partner
thank you chair
uh michael um get back to the level of
service for general rates so if a
passport system came in for
for a service under general rates
and uh property owners who
weren't double vaxxed this would be a
significant change of service to them
as in
it would cease they couldn't go couldn't
use it
so the fact that it is a significant
change of service to them
would this trigger the special
consultative procedure
under the local government act
simplistically the vice that uh is
given by lgnz at the moment is no
because of this this issue around its
uh
you are entitled to
have rules around how you provide the
service so it's not like um
for instance uh council no longer
providing a pool full stop it just has
different rules around how it provides
the pool so it it doesn't trigger those
uh
absolute changes it's a it's a tweak to
the service rather than a a removal of
service is the way that the
interpretation is currently being read
does that help you
it's splitting hairs but that that's the
way the legal advice is coming down from
lg z yeah
okay the same ones doing the three water
thing yeah okay
um
but just for clarity on that for the for
the pool no matter what level we're in
or what service we provide whether it's
vax or novak's it doesn't actually
exclude anyone from that service other
than their own personal choice or their
own personal risk assessment about
whether it's safe to go there so it
won't be us saying you cannot come in
because you're not there there's there's
no issue with that i'm sorry sorry i
misunderstood that i thought a passport
system would stop
a non-vax person from walking in the
front door oh sorry
i was talking about the the existing one
but yes you you are correct yeah and
then their level of service would change
correct
counselor sopa
sorry i wasn't indicating a question my
apologies
have i missed someone counselor amundsen
i'm not sure i want to ask this question
because i'm not sure i want to know the
answer
um
but i'm just wondering where does the
local government act and the full
well-being sit in our assessment of all
of this and our requirement to
promote the social economic
environmental and cultural well-being of
the community
i'm happy to answer that counselor
i thought andrew might have wanted to uh
from a full well-being's point of view
um
with every decision that council has to
make um they have to take those into
consideration in all aspects so
this is no different from that
you have to weigh up the risks the the
um and the benefits and the
opportunities in relation to this in
your decision-making and so it is at the
front of that decision
and the only point that i would add to
that is
i suppose where i started um
[Music]
a lot of the things that are obviously
crossing your mind is around the health
and well-being of the community
um
sitting around this table at the moment
i don't know that we have
any better evidence as to the
uh impact on the health and well-being
of the community than that that's been
considered by the government when they
came up the framework
so clearly when they come up the
framework when you look at what they're
trying to do which was to
minimise the risk and protect the
community
that is just sort of
feeds into those health and well-being
considerations
if you were trying to
make a decision on what is for the best
health of the community you would almost
need to get some specific advice on that
but it's it's there in your decision
making i'm just trying to guide you as
to where you might look to get evidence
of that from
michael
i apologize to councillors there is one
piece of information that i thought you
would be prudent to
let you know that i had missed out which
was that um in relation to our service
centers um for the collection of our our
revenues
our approach during lockdown
is a good example to look at in relation
to how we dealt with the fact that there
are a lot of our community that
do do pay by cash in the fos approach
during lockdown we deferred
and in essence
there was a service that needed to be
provided in relation to that in some way
or
capacity within
invercargill
so we acknowledged that during the
lockdown period and deferred payment so
i just wanted to make sure councillors
were aware of that in relation to
decision making
a useful reminder thanks michael
okay councillors um uh
thank you for your forbearance through
the question
uh section and
sincerely my thanks to the staff so one
of the reasons we're meeting this
afternoon is around i guess the need for
councillors to have more clarity
uh around the position that went out
last week and and ultimately there are
some policy decisions that we
will be making very shortly
it is
very clear that we have had
good advice
that there has been
robust discussion at a staff level
prior to
the the writing of the paper and
and
various scenarios seem to have been
thrashed out which is great because
that's been reflected and how you've all
been able to answer the questions this
afternoon
i'm going to give councillors the the
chance to
make statements or
will give their position before i go
into each of the
um
each of the recommendations individually
because i think
i i've got a sense prior to the meeting
that
councillors wanted to look at things on
a venue-by-venue basis so
see everyone
comfortable with that process
do i have a volunteer who wants to kick
off and and i see that hand and just as
a reminder you might be you can state
what your position is on on the process
and i'm thinking of you better with the
question that you wanted to ask before
but and you can give you reasons behind
it but i wouldn't in that example expect
a question um
this is this is your opportunity to
uh express yourself in the democracy
before we go to a vote so councillor
clark thank you for stepping forward yep
thank you um
my position is i trust the government
advice
and the approach to the cover thing and
i hear a lot of
people and well not a lot of people i
hear people in opposition including
speakers today
new zealand from my perspective is one
of if not the safest country to live in
at the moment and a pandemic and this is
due to the government's very good
stewardship
let's not forget we have a global
pandemic
the government's provided new zealand
with many tools to minimize the harm of
the virus so they are vaccines border
control miq social isolation
alert levels
mask wearing now the traffic lights and
possibly the use of the vaccine
passports these are all tools to allow
us to get a balance between having an
open country where we have some freedom
but also
safeguarding the majority of our systems
so i'm a strong supporter of
using the
vaccine passport tool
in council because it avoids the
opportunity for mass spreading and
ensures clients are safer not
necessarily safe but safer in larger icc
venues so my
support is for the vaccine passports to
be used in the pool and the library but
nowhere else at this stage on the
proviso that as we go further into the
opening up of auckland we may want to
reset the parameters um on a regular
basis and review that we've got right
for the other venues just as a matter of
clarification counselor you would be
excluding those venues for example like
the civic theater that we're already
requiring it yes that's already that's
already covered so i'm quite happy with
the status quo for this building
um and for bluff
but certainly the lottery and the
and the pool have large attendance rates
and so
if we get that wrong the potential for a
super speed as i head with nalcon with
the pacific island church scenario
gets it really out of control
given that in southam we don't have a
lot of facilities that may be available
one of us so our nearest miq
for people to isolate in if they can't
isolate at home is in dunedin
so i'm i'm happy to
go down at the track of just having um
just for those two venues that's all my
approaches thank you this is cool
um
hi do you want to pull that microphone
and click
i actually um
also trust the public health system
advice um
[Music]
i i do struggle with that the comment
that was made earlier around the
unbacked sound claim because i don't
believe that's the case to me
people have the right to be vaccinated
or not that's their choice it's their
body
and
as we have a right to protect the health
and wellbeing of our communities
and so that's sort of where i'm
soliciting
and how i feel
so
just to seek clarification funny you you
were um suggesting that the passport
um i'm supportive of the passport
but um
i would not want to exclude people in
certain places like the pool
for example
or you know
the public library but
um if that was the the choice of our my
colleagues here but that's katie pie
right so your position is kind of around
the recommendations that we've currently
got councillor lewis
of similar
thoughts that mrs coot
things like hey waka tour i think we
would have possible
because
it's very difficult to maintain the
spaces in areas like that i know there's
a number quantity
i tend to be on the more cautious side
we i know we've had a public
submission from two varies at school
will not as well help people and
not necessarily my
thoughts we've all read so much about it
i think we should be guided by the the
governmental laws as much as we can down
the tractor we have uniformity
throughout new zealand
i er on this on-site caution
the pools
more room i think a bit lovely the
library
the
it's a difficult one
i find it very hard to be totally
definitive across the board i'm afraid
of the stage but i would err and look on
the
thank you
councillor cricket
uh thank you councillor i think this is
a really um
awkward position to be in because it's
kind of like you damned if you do and
you damn if you don't
um
i
truly believe that people are really
free to choose like i really strongly
believe that they're absolutely free to
choose but they're not free from the
consequences of it
um it's been spoken about today by the
lovely nikki um personal responsibility
is a huge thing when it comes to the
balance of risk
around how you are individually treating
your own personal risk to
covet
but in doing that too you're also
putting the people around you
at a heightened risk and we do i like my
colleagues i do trust the government's
advice and epidemiology and health
around this
i think that if we made a move to make
uh vaccine passes mandatory in our
larger entities that that will actually
segregate more people from attendance
because like
ms cook actually uh spoke about earlier
that puts another
larger portion of the um
populous or ir populous at risk as well
the data doesn't lie we've seen it right
across the world
uh that's why the government has
indicated exactly what it has
it's a really delicate balance of risk
that ethically i
personally
can't
put more people at risk or make a
decision to put more people at risk
when i have something in my power within
our power sorry that we can do to try to
reduce risk for the wider community
we have to take the lead from the
experts and like i said
previously
when people in our community do become
sick i would really like to see this
council be able to be agile in our
response and tighten up on restrictions
if we see fit
um
and just you know balance that
comfortability of risk within our
council how how much risk are we
actually willing to to take in the
community where do we decide that that
breakpoint is where the risk is too
great and we like ms um coat has said
what mrs cooter said uh tighten those up
as the
risk becomes greater
thank you so tim
yes well
to me freedom is a word that's sort of
sacred and it's one of the great
advantages we've got
at living in new zealand has been
pointed out
but
it's times in your life when you have to
over or are overwhelmed by
the assault on our well-being that's
taking place
and if you've got children and
grandchildren
the burden of
the decision that we're making tonight
is enhanced
but um
nonetheless my
gene
general sort of belief is that
we've got to
harden up in this case
we've just got to
do the best we can
and
the real answer i've have to so many of
the issues about data
is we just don't know
and when you're interviewed in that and
you say you don't know they look at you
like
you're a leper or something
and um
we've got we're going to learn a lot
from this and one day i think we'll look
back on it and be able to say to our
great grandchildren
wow
a bit like those who faced the
depression in two world wars
we were there for the great
[Music]
battle against
the
plague that's infested us
thank you councillor skelt
thank you cheer um
a big thank you to the medical
presenters this afternoon it was very
outstanding
and what they did say
um but the contrary to that obviously is
um for me
quite clearly is this council need to
show some leadership around this issue
because without a shadow of a doubt
being involved in one of the larger
venues what i've seen since friday to
today
and the venue that probably put through
four and a half thousand people over the
weekend
um there's a misconception about people
on the tv the double vex
so of those people that came with the
venue for councillors to
to give you some comfort ninety-five
percent of them were actually
very happy
with being asked to be double facts
showing that vaccination pass with a
very small percentage
the next step of that obviously we're
talking about a population of less than
10 percent that we're making a decision
for
on what we're doing unvaccinated versus
vaccinated
i can't agree with my fellow colleagues
around the government's performance
around this particular issue in the
traffic light issue
and
i stayed this it's been appalling
from an information and communication
they couldn't run a hot bath on this
particular issue
in the sense of their communication
it's made it exceptionally difficult
you've heard from richard today
and it's exceptional different for venue
managers and the particularly the
hospitality industry so that's why i've
asked those direct questions today
of the individuals who have experience
in that field
if we could have some consistency
there's no shadow of a doubt in my mind
that we covered is going to hit us
without a shadow of a doubt and we need
to be prepared we need to be consistent
in our message and our communication and
our delivery across all our venues
without a shadow of a doubt
our people who are our most important
asset are confused they are living in
fear because this government
this government has made an appalling
their communication around this process
has been nothing short of appalling in
my opinion in my professional opinion
of running a large multi-purpose
multi-functional venue it has put undue
stress on staff and the public
across all of those menus so the plea is
for council this council is to show some
leadership
and i'm moving towards that all of our
venues
all of our venues should be double
vaxxed
councillor
[Applause]
rabbit no i'll come back to that thanks
just listening at the moment
well we're doing the round table
when are you expecting to go
go
where when are we expecting your
comments feedback
oh just want to hear a few other
comments please well we're halfway
around the room
yeah i realize that i'm not
sorry
does have the right to speak at any time
he wants to and not follow a sequence
counselor sopa
thank you mr chair um
first of all i do feel obliged to
declare that i have probably had
more access to the science and the data
and the preparation and use of icu
facilities than other councillors and
i'm not going to go into any sort of
lecture on that except to say i'm sure
our local dhv covert experts
would be happy to brief council and
answer any questions about the accuracy
of health information
and there has been some unfortunate
comments about inaccuracies and
falsities today that i am very disturbed
by
um i will also declare
um that i am of the opinion that the
world has not managed the pandemic well
new zealand had the chance to do it
better
and we did
coming now to council and where we are
now council has the option
to determine whether to use the vaccine
passport for air public facilities
in my opinion and i'm very happy to
declare this council
and for that matter other civic leaders
do need to show a lead on this issue
we discussed that very point a few
meetings ago ago when i think councillor
lush
raised the possibility of council taking
some leads on the covet issue here's
an ideal chance for us to show that
council is prepared to take a leave
i
i feel that we do have a duty to
mitigate risk
and to protect the health and safety of
vulnerable people
i will refer in particular to the
vulnerable
immuno-compromised people
who we know will choose not to use our
facilities our library our pools
tarakatoria etc
if
the unvaccinated
have the access
i think we should not be any doubt in
any doubt at all
that while we may lose
some
unvaccinated people if we choose the
route of
requiring the vaccine passport we will
lose a
large number of vulnerable
immunocompromised people than we know
are large users
of air facilities such as the library if
we do not take the vaccine passport
group
so i do believe that we as council have
the ability and the duty to take a lead
it does fit within the four well-beings
consideration and i have considered all
four aspects of the well-beings and
saying this
i do think we have the chance to take
a real lead on this issue and that is
where i stand
councillor lush
yeah i look i am
i think that people out there are scared
um and rightly so you know it's um
the tick tock of the pandemic coming
closer
um and people want to go out and about
and experience and have a normalcy that
they can and i think for the double
vaccine it gives them that normalcy
it enables them to go to the places they
like to go the majority of the people
over 92 percent people like by new years
will be double vaccinated
slightly lower down here but that's
because we've been away from the
pandemic but it's coming
it's in fiordland it's in lake monaway
at the green hut today
so you know i think it's very important
and my understanding is the reason we've
got
vaccine passports for the libraries in
the pools is to project protect the
under 12
and the under five-year-olds that can't
get vaccinated
that's why we've got it there so they
can go there and read their books and
run around and swim and do their lessons
and do that
knowing that the unvaccinated won't come
and they're more likely to have the
illness and more likely to spread it and
that's the whole reason behind it
is to keep those people safe and keep
normalcy happening there for them
so i think it's very very important that
we
do pass this
i also think that
just knowing with the pull so far is
that
going to swimming lessons at the pool
you're required to wear masks
most people don't or they have them on
their chin it seems as though the people
given the start the self-regulating way
that people can
make the right choices for themselves
they don't do that they seem to
treat the thing as a whole joke and
don't take it very seriously at all
also some comments about
the council being discriminatory
i can't work out how it can be
discriminatory because the vaccine
is free
and here
and available to anyone so i can't quite
work out who it's discriminatory against
and that's the bit i can't quite work
out you know 92 of people
by new years will be double vaccinated
and those people want to get out there
and have a normal life and want to have
things as normal as possible they're the
people that were told
if they get vaccinated freedoms would be
there for them and i think it's
duty-bound for us to
to respond to that so yeah look um
certainly and i also think too for
listening to peter's question or as a
tempered question i think
the counselors in this council chamber
also probably we um er on the probably
the side of the elderly um etc i think
councillors have the right to come
and debate policy in a safe where it's
safe where they're not nervous of people
they're unvaccinated coming here to
these meetings as well so i think i'd
also be in favor of the chamber being a
place that you had to be double
vaccinated to be
so um yeah as far as the service centres
i realize the rates are essential i
think probably i'd prefer those to be
just open spaces at the stage
thanks
thank you
peter yeah thank you chairman
uh as an elected city councillor i
believe as part of my job
keep our citizens
and visitors as safe as we possibly can
and for months now i've been urging
people both young and old to be double
backed
next saturday the 11th of december we've
got a huge race meeting in the cargo up
to 4 000 people attended
and the organizers who like getting
people of their own costume
having people there to enjoy and to bet
and whatever
i have made it very very clear
four thousand are attending
if they haven't
have their double facts they will not be
allowed on course
i would also like to applaud the
southern stadium south and staff
where there's about 12 000 people go
through there weekly
and
i've done a brilliant job
by saying
no
no facts
oh it matters
getting to
splash palace
a large number of our elderly people go
to splash palace both male and female
and a lot of them for health and fitness
reasons alone
look we must protect our elderly
and all our pool users
and we should not be putting them at
risk
so for all our venues i'm including the
library
splash palace most definitely
if they haven't got a vaccine pass
sorry you cannot come in
thanks counselor counselor amundsen
when it comes to the health of our
community and our country i think new
zealand has done a really good job
i think that it's been really easy to
forget since august this year that for
the 12 months preceding that
we've actually pretty much been living
normal life here in new zealand
and so i think from a health perspective
things for us have been
coped with very well and i've got
friends and i know people overseas
i know people here who have lost family
members
whose family members have had to live a
very restricted life for the last nearly
two years
and i think it's very easy for us to
take for granted
the position that we are in
i do however think that it's quite
interesting that the government's
requirements around public facilities
appear to be the same when it comes to
vaccination certificates or not
and also seem to be the same whether
you're in the orange light or the red
light more or less with a slight
difference however
like general businesses across new
zealand we also have been given the same
choice about whether we want to put in
place vaccination certificates or not
and so
i think it's been talked about already
that people need to take some personal
responsibility
with how they
engage in a in a covert environment but
i think it's important that we have to
remember as elected members that we also
have a responsibility to our community
to be making decisions that take into
account um some of the things that we
can help and assist with
i think the full well-beings very
clearly tell us and local government
that we are here to promote
social economic environmental and
cultural well-being
and i think as much as the facilities
that we run our public facilities they
are also for the public and 90 of our
public more or less has had their first
vaccination
um or more
and i think that if we went down the
road of having no public uh no covered
vaccine passports then we are actually
going to be disadvantaging
the 90 of our community who have been
vaccinated
on the flip side by using vaccine
passports in our facilities like the
library in the swimming pool and
hawakituya
we are actively protecting the 90 of
people who are vaccinated but we're also
actually protecting the unvaccinated
people and that's the 10 of people who
choose not to be vaccinated
and all of the children and people who
are not able to have the vaccine so my
preference is certainly to
have our public facilities like the
library the swimming pool and hawakituya
as vaccine passport places but i can
appreciate that having
downstairs here and
the bluff service center which are
providing
essential services yes and also places
where people are only going to be going
for a short amount of time and so
therefore the risk is less if you are
using the risk process um profile thing
thank you
councillor partner
thank you chair um
first thing um credibility of the
passport system
uh you require two vaxes to get that
now
the person who got their second backs
back in january this year
is unable to get a passport and they
have the same status
as
yes as as anyone who they are double
backs no booster shot required yeah
they're double maxed they are double
backs so they've had their last one
but they're double backs and we and it
is facts and dr sophie mentioned that
and it is fact and i've heard it from
people at pfizer that the vaccine wears
off and that's why you need to boost the
booster as evidence that it wears off
after six months now how can you issue
passports to those people
who
have elapsed clearly 10 months
of
of their from their last vaccine it
doesn't make any sense there's no logic
here um i mean i like to make decisions
based on logic and that's one thing i
can't quite understand the other thing
that's
everyone seems to ignore and it's
sitting right in front of us as a
control experiment as supermarkets now
there is no reported
factual transmission
in supermarkets they know there has not
been
completely
the transmission rate people
is incredibly low
so people
of
being vexed or non-vex congregate there
you don't know who's faxed or unboxed
and it works
so i mean i this passport thing just
just i struggled to understand it for
the reasons i said before i just can't
understand it if there was some
consistency and they said yeah sorry
six months was up it's like a warrant on
your car your passport is invalid you
need another jab that would make sense
i would then buy into it but until it
makes sense
so it's to me it's not making any sense
i i do not support the passport system
whatsoever and council facilities i mean
the civic and hayward county don't worry
me
but it does
for the library
and the pool and i would like to see
those
non-passported
for those very reasons
there is no logical case
is it a question oh just a clarification
uh
on my vaccine pass
my vaccine pass expires on the first of
june next year and you have to go for a
booster and then you'll have another
vaccine passed
issued so it's like a driver's license
or a warrant of fitness of your car
thanks thanks for the clarification
yep
let's
cook i don't know who was double vaxxed
in january it's a mythical person
because there wasn't vaccine available
and it cannot possibly have been to
double backs last at this january
not in new zealand
um sorry
um facts are facts we need to stick to
facts
i think
from for me and for my family
the memory of the effects of the
1918-1919
pandemic
are
enduring in our ulupa in our cemetery
the parents and the two children that
were lost
that were my partners grandparents and
great aunts and uncles the proof is
there
and what happened is that our people
stopped going
and doing the things with one another
that they had done traditionally
they turned in and looked after
themselves but our urupa had not been
used until that time there had been no
necessity to use that place it was set
aside
by atupana for that purpose
so
if we come forward
in my lifetime
i watch my cousins struggle with polio i
saw the effects on my aunt of polio i
lost an art to tuberculosis
nobody in this room now
experiences those things and if you're
under the age of 60 you probably don't
even know that it was a real issue
but it was
you know i had an uncle nearly died of
measles
he was 35
that doesn't happen anymore or it
shouldn't happen in this day and age
when we know about vaccination we know
about cause and effect
none of us can really escape
the fact that covert is
changing
and will continue to change until it
doesn't have people to be vectors for it
anymore that's the
as i understand it that's the nature of
how these things work
the more people who have immunity the
more people who
um have protection
and the more sensible we are about how
we do things
the less it's likely to spread and
affect us but the biggest thing of all
is that as part of a
a thousand year business
i look at what
i am doing
to make things better both for those who
are older than me
and the for those who are too young
to take those precautions for whom we
have a responsibility
so
when i
am faced with a kaumatua who is actively
dying at this point who has had both
vaccinations and a booster who am i to
say to him
you should go amongst people who choose
not to be vaccinated i'm not talking
about those who can't
those who choose not to be vaccinated
because they believe that this
illness does not exist or that it isn't
fatal or any of those things the right
circumstances provide prevailing
it will be fatal if you are predisposed
as many of our
community are
you have underlying health conditions
you are so much more at risk
and i think that we as councillors or
spokespeople for the people that we
represent
so i am the mangai for waihoopwa i
talked to them last night
we know that will it this may impact on
some of our people that they may not be
able to go to places that
they would like to go but many of them
feel unsafe about going into places
where they have no certainty that the
people with whom they are associating
have taken the same health precautions
as they have if we look at our
responsibility to
those we represent
then the majority have taken
the overwhelming majority
have taken
the opportunity
to take up the vaccination
they have taken the opportunity to look
at themselves and their families and
make those decisions on their behalf and
on behalf of those who cannot be
vaccinated because they are either too
young
or are compromised
the chances of us being the vectors to
them
i believe
are much less if we take these sensible
precautions
i am indicating that apart from the
absolute
spaces that must be retained open
and that means including this space that
we
aim for vaccination passports
to all our facilities
for the betterment of all of the people
of this area not just
the ones who are not vaccinated
councillor abbott
oh thank you i
fully agree with that last comment that
um
the
places that should be
double vaccinated include this chamber
and i just want to speak about
the immune compromised
i fall into that category
and
we have penalties too i mean it's been
said that the people that are
unvaccinated are penalized but we are
penalized as well and i've been a
recluse
predominantly under medical orders for
three months or more
and
i was told
certainly that if covert hit me i would
not be a candidate for staying at home
so you can draw your own conclusions
from that
so my personal choice now is to
not knowingly
work with or be associated with the
unvaccinated
and i know that might sound harsh but
the concerns are very real to me because
as i say
of me and many others who have
compromised immune systems
today uh i think councillor lush touched
on it about fjordland um it's at our
back doorstep um
he first conducted a first week positive
um
and it was a weak positive and the
second day was
negative but that's not to say
that something couldn't develop
so i hold immense values in the right of
freedom and i believe that
the unvaccinated
with the exemption of medical or other
grounds like that
um had
the knowledge that
if they weren't vaccinated they would be
in some shape or form penalties i.e that
they couldn't attend certain functions
so i
i
agree that we should
adopt the system of
vaccinations or passes
throughout
our public's places excluding the um
two
chambers the lower labor not the
chambers sorry the lower level and
indeed bluff service center so that's my
thoughts i've thought long and hard and
i thought about the position of the
unvaccinated but i still believe that
people had the obligation to support
themselves their whanau their family
their friends and extended friendships
like
around this table i think we should all
be looking at
a place that we could feel safe in and a
double vaccination whilst i know it
doesn't exempt you from catching
corona um
i think it's essential that this place
also be double vaccinated
that's my thoughts
thanks lindsay
similarly as an immuno-compromised
person
um
i have a really vested interest in the
whole
situation although i heart back to
what mrs hadley said earlier on about
keeping an open mind and it's been
interesting through through this process
and and i thank you for your questions
for your comments i thank the staff for
their input and i thank the submitters
who've come and spoken to us in public
forum because i've kind of parts of me
have bounced around
but i think part of the problem
with society at the moment is that
people are scared
and people are behaving quite poorly as
a result of it
which is part of the reason why i've
taken an unusually authoritarian stance
around the process today about
maintaining
respect
uh and that's part of the the charter
that we all signed into because people
will have different perspectives i
really
have a great deal of sympathy for those
who are not able to be vaccinated
there are others who who have a choice
and choose not to for for whatever
position
uh whatever information uh they have and
and you know we had
uh in and dr sophie earlier on somebody
who has been an expert witness uh
in a court case and
through rma processes i'm quite familiar
with the process that you've got to go
through to
to
be an expert witness
but part of that decision making
framework that i quite often use is
about how you apply weight
and and i also look at what's been
suggested by the director of general of
health who kind of sits at the top of
that poll as far as our country
hierarchy goes
um
i think we've got to be
continue to be nimble
as an organization because
i agree with some comments that the
information that the lack of clarity
that's that's come out has
been most unhelpful
um
and that's from central government
but
i have always been really impressed with
how nimble
we've been as an organisation
and how we respond to it how we've
restructured the way we do business
uh as a as a as a tla and as a a
democracy you know the way that we are
operating now is is very different to at
the start of this term
and and a great deal of that is as a
result of of the the first covet
outbreak
which
i will take a moment to remind you
included a particularly severe one in
bluff
which touched this very organization
i
respect those unable to be vaccinated i
accept those who make a choice
not to be
i have no time for people who
who get angry with each other
um
then i had somebody lunge at me because
i chose to walk down the street wearing
my face mask
and it's like really because because i
didn't have a crack at you for not
wearing one
i think you make your choices i
maintained a respectful distance
i think i'll be nimble in how i respond
to things
with the impending outbreak which which
you know will be here if it's not in
fiordland now it'll be here by the end
of next week
once um auckland relocates to queenstown
it's june island
i thought they were there
um
i say that lightly but you know it's
we we know that
by going through a vaccination process
you give
yourself
to the best of my knowledge and i don't
have a degree the the best chance of
of
surviving as an immuno-compromised
person
of
not
passing it on but it's not a panacea you
know it's not a guarantee it just it
reduces
um and there will still be people who
are who are vaccinated
um
who
will test positive for covert and the
assorted variants that are in
circulation and and those who don't
but i come back to a point that a couple
of councillors have made and that's
around leadership
and and from that perspective i just
really encourage people to um to get
vaccinated
as i say i'm triple dipped now which
makes me feel like an ice cream um
probably not as tasty
and in another six months go through
that process of being boosted again and
again
and again as long as i'm allowed that's
that's fine
uh
to be fair the reaction that i've had
has been nothing apart from that that
sore arm
i have seen very severe reactions in
others
and i understand that
but we're being asked to provide
leadership
the one thing i don't want to do
is impose on people's democratic rights
to participate in democracy
and to come in
and to be able to do the normal business
with council that we had to suspend and
you know we
held off on allowing
rates payments to be made for a while
during the last lockdown
i think it's imperative that a service
centre in bluff that the civic
administration building first floor
and even
this room and our other meeting spaces
are open to all
i know i have a choice
in attending meetings here that if i was
not comfortable and that would depend
entirely on
what's going on in the community
regardless of the person on the other
side of the room or next to me or around
me somewhere not being vaccinated is
actually going to dictate how i behave
you know there will be a time when i
know i need to take
more care
um
because the other person sitting next to
me or across me or around me somewhere
who is vaccinated could also
be positive with covet
so it's that it's that fine balancing
act
um with the initial
indications of how we wanted to apply it
when they came out i
i struggled with uh splash palace i kind
of thought of it as human soup and i
don't mean that disrespectfully but
everyone's in the same order
and it's kind of humid
um but i've really appreciated the the
explanations that we've had around that
and and the different spaces
from from the staff
i've felt that
the library is actually quite an open
space
um
and and
as busy as it is
never that packed it's not like on a
countdown you know
when it can get
phenomenally busy
hawkituya our new talker and uh kelvin
street
similarly people going in there and
enjoying it but
not packed and that's fine because
actually it's it's quite
spacious
and again if i if i felt uncomfortable
in some places um i can remove myself
and i did that last year after the
release of the first lockdown and you
know half of invica went to tr now and
the other half went to queenstown
i was in queenstown where there were
many places who
you know i weren't really policing
people scanning in and sanitizing and uh
certainly no distancing going on
um and so i made a choice actually i'm
not comfortable in the space i'll leave
it
but we are in a position we are where we
are expected to uh to provide some
leadership
and that is the point that we're at now
where we get to make those choices as
the representatives for our community i
am confident
that around the table
cert people who do represent each part
of our community and the different
perspectives and i'm comforted by that
because you know if it were to be a
simple rubber stamping process that that
would be a disappointment
it's it's a weighty emotive issue um and
and i thank you for the way that we've
gone through it so far
hopefully at the other end uh we will
similarly uh pack it away
and and
look to what it is that we have to to
deal with next because there's no
shortage of things
and the issue around covert is a
continually evolving one that
we will as i say need to be nimble and
respond to as the situation changes
so the first one's really easy oops i
thought it was a touch screen for a
minute there um
that the report cover prediction
framework and vaccine passports for
council services and facilities be
received i'm looking for a movie
but i think we need discussion of
counselor clinton
okay
i'll put the motion all in favor
again
the second point is that we note council
operates public facilities as defined in
the covert protection framework and
again i don't know that there's
any way we can dissent from that
councillor amundsen i could move that
one in the the next one after
happy to second both of those
two and three thank you that makes good
sense thank you councillors
um oh any discussion
put the motion all in favor
against
carried
item four is that we confirm where
venues namely the civic theatre rugby
park and scottish hall operates events
remembering there is a different a
different definition around events that
sits in in that in that framework
uh that those events must comply with
the requirements for events as set out
in the card protection framework i'll
move that
saying to council again open for
discussion
i'll put that all in favor
against
carried
uh
gatherings at the cemetery or chapel
again these uh are relatively
prescribed in in numbers who can attend
that we confirm that we're gatherings at
the cemetery or chapel occur these
gatherings must comply with requirements
for gatherings as set out
ms cook and councillor edmondson thank
you
open for discussion
i'll put that all in favor
against
carried
the next one's where it gets a bit lumpy
so with your indulgence
can i skip to seven
because i think that will set a tone for
us to come back to six
how the next few go mr chair i respect
what you do i think the point is you're
operating within a cover protection
framework
that's the overarching truth i'll take
that
mover
councillor lewis
any comments
i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried
right now we're now down to the uh
ground floor of the civic administration
building the recommendation is that uh
vaccine passes
uh be required or not required this cook
i moved that flexing passes be not
required for entry to the customers i'll
second that thank you councillor abbott
questions or comments
i'll put that all in favor
against
carried
against
thanks councillor scott noted
uh
resolution eight that vaccine passes be
required or not required for entry to
the council chamber and or meeting rooms
first floor of the civic administration
building does somebody want to move in
one direction
i'll move that they'll be required
i'll second that
moved uh councillor abbott seconded
councillor sopa
yes um
i think i've got a feeling that around
the room the consensus for this is going
to be that they are required for this
council chamber
and not not predetermining a vote but
that's just my feeling with what
everybody's been saying as we've gone
around the table
um i think councilor lalo you touched on
it that um
i in no way really want to be in any in
any way responsible for being
prohibitive to democracy so i want to
make sure that when we
are making this decision that we have
our electronic means of zooming in for
public forum
or
making sure that our live streams are
always
consistent and available and accessible
in the public education of that
accessibility to participate in
democracy for the um
the non 92 percent of us that is not
vaccinated
is not prohibitive in any way
thank you so can you remind me who the
mover and secondary
move counselor abbott second council
says that they'd be
that vaccine passes be
required
for entry to the council chamber
okay
any further questions or comments
i'll put that to the vote all in favor
aye
aye against
no
i think you show our hands around that
one
all those in favor you could raise your
hands
against one two
three
thank you
motion is carried
that vaccine passes be required or not
required for entry into the bluff
service center or library looking for a
mover
and library required
sorry you were moving that they are not
required was that depending
you're moving that way
thank you so not required seconded
council amundsen
councillor cricket thank you i mean
we're viewing this under the same lens
as we would for the customer service
centre for the ground floor of this
building that it is an essential service
and people need to be able to access it
in that same manner
so not required is the motion counselor
lush can we make an amendment and break
out the library has been separate or
does that become
is it practical is
part of the same building really
councillors
it's
quite
um communal trudy is trying very hard to
be um
accommodating but the the practical
reality is no
okay so we'll leave them together
not required for uh the bluff service
center and library is the motion
i'll put that all in favor i
i
against
carried
sorry councillor scout you'd like yours
recorded thank you thank you
uh
and direction required for the bluff
municipal chambers
well i'd assume nothing because it was
different here
who's moving
you're well yeah i'm looking for a
direction
required thank you okay so the mover is
going for required for the bluff
municipal chambers is there a seconder
for that please second
thank you councillor
that's open for discussion
mr chair even though it sounds
contradictory
because of the technical difficulties
for people zooming
into or out of
the bluff municipal chambers
and because of the quite small group
that actually meets at that time
i'm a little bit ambivalent about
imposing
um
vaccine passports on that and i stand to
be corrected but i i i think the space
is adequate for the number of people who
normally attend
however
i think the technical
if we resolve the technical issues there
i would feel um
[Music]
vaccine passports were necessary but
because we haven't yet resolved them i i
don't want to um preclude democracy
correct this is cool we have no wi-fi so
we would not be able to
adhere to that
councillor lewis
just indulge me i think we did pass that
we would pay for wi-fi in the black
community chamber some time ago
and it was discussed the bluff community
bought at one stage and it was
i'm pretty sure we passed it the full
council meeting mr day
um through yourself to your yes
counselor that is correct and we're in
the process of implementing wi-fi into
that facility
but it is not there yet
is there a time frame
i think my comment would be that uh it's
in a lot it's in a long line
of technology projects and without
wishing to sound unkind
the value proposition for it as opposed
to for instance supporting counsellors
with ipads and other things it's
one of the lesser priorities it's a
harsh reality i'm sorry
so not in a hurry no well i i i'm
embarrassed
okay the motion is that a vaccine passes
be required for the bluffing municipal
chambers
which is wi-fi list counselor clark just
a further comment on that um
i'm a bit uneasy i guess that we
we require a passport to come here but
we've got other options for people to
zoom in and to
live stream and
yet
we're asking the bluff center or bluff
area to
sort of be at the end of a long list of
i.t needs and i think
that changes my view on it unless we can
give some urgency to that wi-fi upgrade
then i'm probably going to be opposed
i'm sitting here
sorry lin just a moment through yourself
chair i'll remind council that they only
um approved the wi-fi not for full live
streaming um option um it will not be
able to be live streamed from that
perspective it is just wi-fi access
counselor abbott
i know it's just hoping that it could be
a priority that was all but after
hearing this today well
councillor sopa
thank you mr chair i my comment would be
that if we pass
this particular motion to be consistent
with what we have passed for the council
chamber then we have indicated that we
want this to be the highest the
priorities for
to come up to the 21st century with
wi-fi
and streaming
counseling thank you i was just going to
make a suggestion if it wouldn't be too
arduous that perhaps the bluff community
board while
for the just the short interim while the
wi-fi situation gets fixed could come up
here
that's assuming that uh the community
board and anybody wishing to speak to
them have the ability to do that
councillor lewis yeah that might not be
totally practical though
because the bluff community helped me to
start at seven in the evening we would
not have
personally i'm sitting in the know for
this at the moment but i'd revisit it
when there's
better um
electronic services
well it's been moved and seconded i'm
happy to test the motion
so no i'm gonna well you can't move an
amendment against your motion
no
it's a nice thought and i understand the
sentiment counsellor but i will test it
i'll put the motion all in favor sorry
councillor sopa
all right before you put the motion can
i just um remind people that i think
there is only
one further bluff community board
meeting due this year i think it is next
monday
[Music]
and by the time of the next block
community board meeting i would hazard
if we make it a priority that the um
the technological situation i don't i
don't know that we can guarantee that
type of magic leslie mr cheer
i need the council laws to all hear mr
day's advice
wi-fi does not equal live streaming
okay i just want to remember so
remembering that
fibre
hasn't hit the bluff yet
parts
as somebody who
employs a technical person who lives in
bluff
they are challenged after hours
so i'm going to test the motion all
those that support the motion that
vaccine passes be required for entry to
the bluff municipal chambers i
against
no
all right we'll go back to a show at
hand sorry all those in who supports the
motion that they'd be required hands
please
one two three four
five six
those against
one two three four five six seven
motion is lost
so therefore um
by default do i need a new motion
yes
the the motion that i will then put as
the vaccine passes are not required for
entry to the bluff municipal chambers is
there a secondary councillor clerk thank
you
don't need to rehash it all those in
favor aye aye
again
thank you who would like their votes
recorded thank you yes councillor keith
councillor scout councillor sopa
councillor abbott have i missed anyone
thank you for that
uh
the eve paul public library
council at evansville i'll move i'll
move that back send passes are required
i'll second that in that case
okay
moved and segmented
all in favor aye aye aye
against
yes no
carried
no vote recorded please yep
um
splash palace
i move that vaccine passes are required
thank you councillor kit is there a
second
discussion
vote all in favor aye aye
against
carried
the vaccine passes be required or not
required for access to the animal
control facility
i'll test this one with a with a not
required simply because it's limited
access entry
seconded counselor crack it
comment or discussion
i just think we should be consistent i
hear what you're saying but i think we
should be consistent understand that but
there's already variation between
different facilities
i understand that mr chair the guidance
does require you to provide an
alternative access
you'll notice that the resolution is not
for entry but it is to access
it's difficult to see how you could
provide an alternative service
when you're talking about the handing
over a dog
there it goes good luck have a run
for those little ones that are really
fast
okay i'll put the motion uh that it's
not required all in favor aye
against
councillor scout would you like your
vote recorded thank you thank you
and councillor sober do you want your
vote recorded please
councillor soper
i voted for i beg your pardon
it's misinformation for you it's
everywhere
i think you might be meaning counselor
ever
no no no he's he's in a different
position
i was just going on what i read on
facebook okay if uh vaccination passes
are confirmed this requirement be
introduced from monday december 13
moved ms cook seconded councillor
amundsen
all in favor
[Music]
resolution 16 that council ensure as far
as practical compliance with the code of
protection framework for all users of
council property for gatherings outdoor
community gatherings or events
as defined in the code of protection
framework so move seconded by
mrs coop
all in favor
against
kerry
councillors may i
close with the comment that
while some people will be happy others
will be equally disappointed
but i am comfortable that we have
represented the very
various views that exist within our
community and
i thank you for the way which you've
conducted the discussion we now have an
in-committee meeting for the
infrastructural services committee so i
will close this meeting and thank you
for your participation
yeah we'll take a five minute comfort
stop councillors
yeah it's fun
i'll tell you when to say hi
you